alors bienvenue à cette session qui pourrait
ont été appelés apocalypse maintenant donc je
vous parlera des conséquences
du changement climatique
eh bien pas maintenant tout de suite pour être honnête
il y a une partie qui attendra un peu
alors
la dernière fois que je t'ai parlé de la dynamique
au travail dans ce que nous appelons communément
changement climatique
donc il y a une chose que je n'ai pas tout à fait fait
terminer lors de mon aperçu de la dernière fois
parce que dans les substances que les humains
mettre dans l'atmosphère il y a de
bien sûr les gaz à effet de serre que j'ai
vous en a longuement parlé mais il y a
aussi une autre catégorie de substances
que les hommes mettent dans l'atmosphère qui
est appelé aérosols et aérosol
précurseurs
l'âme si étroite dans le langage physique est
simplement une suspension dans l'air d'un liquide
ou des particules solides pour que toutes les personnes
dans cette pièce qui a déjà balayé un balai
s'il y en a à qui c'est arrivé oui
bien
vous avez créé un aérosol dessus
occasion puisque vous avez créé un
suspension dans l'air de particules solides
si vous avez balayé un peu vigoureusement
dans le euh
dans les éléments que l'homme met dans
atmosphère et qui peut créer
suspensions de l'air que vous avez réellement
tous les deux
éléments qui sont émis directement comme euh
sous forme liquide ou solide
et qui créera alors des suspensions
par exemple costume
costumes est une suspension dans l'air de
particules de carbone et donc ça fait partie du
aérosols
et puis vous avez des substances qui vont
créer les aérosols une fois dans l'air
c'est-à-dire qu'il est émis dans le
forme gazeuse et une fois dans l'air
alors la réaction a lieu qui va
tourne bien le euh
produits chimiques en liquide et solide
particules et donc là-dedans vous avez un
catégorie très importante qui est le soufre
dioxyde so2 qui une fois dans l'atmosphère
va créer des particules de sulfate qui sont
brillant et particulièrement réfléchissant
particules à la lumière du soleil
et donc il y a cette euh particularité pour
exemple que le particulièrement
combustibles contenant du soufre qui sont utilisés
par la marine marchande
avoir un effet de refroidissement à court terme qui
est supérieur à son effet de chauffage et i
disons à court terme car les aérosols finissent
être perché de l'atmosphère dans
notamment par les précipitations par exemple
pour les aérosols soufrés ça finit par donner
les pluies acides dans lesquelles le sulfate d'um se dissout
de l'eau quand il y a de l'eau et ça fait
un peu d'acide sulfurique que l'on aime
beaucoup une fois qu'il nous arrive sur le terrain
et donc vous avez aussi un autre effet
ce qui est important dans les effets de
aérosols qui est que ces petits
des particules liquides ou solides peuvent être utilisées comme
noyaux de nucléation pour favoriser la
condensation de vapeur d'eau à partir de
nuages ​​et on s'est notamment rendu compte
qu'au-dessus des zones très fortement
industrialisé
les nuages ​​qui se forment sont constitués de
particules un peu plus fines et
qui précipitent un peu moins facilement
alors
cela n'a pas nécessairement d'effet sur
couverture nuageuse mais d'autre part sur
comportement de cette couverture nuageuse, il a une
effet de sorte que les émissions humaines peuvent également
modifier un peu la nature des nuages
que nous trouverons au-dessus de nos têtes
quand les particules émises alors je viens
retour au costume sont noirs évidemment que
intensifie le chauffage car il
augmente la quantité de rayonnement solaire
absorbée d'autre part lorsque le
les particules sont généralement brillantes comme le
sulfates
c'est l'inverse
augmenter l'albédo et donc
diminuer la quantité de rayonnement solaire
absorbés par la surface de sorte que ces
les aérosols peuvent avoir un réchauffement ou un refroidissement
effet selon leur nature
mais dans l'ensemble, ils partagent tous le
caractéristique d'être de courte durée
espèce d'accord ce sont toutes des espèces
qui aura une influence sur la
énergie
les échanges dans l'atmosphère qui sont
raisonnablement
court terme
effets
donc ici vous avez un aperçu de la
différentes substances qui sont émises dans
l'atmosphère et qui ont un effet
essentiellement sur la réflexion de la
rayonnement solaire sauf pour suit ou la
sri en français ou noir de carbone
donc là mais sinon pour la plupart
c'est
entre guillemets effets de refroidissement à court terme
ce graphique que vous trouvez dans à peu près
chaque édition des rapports du GIEC fait
à ce moment une évaluation de tous les
effets de réchauffement et de refroidissement de tous
substances que l'humanité met dans
atmosphère donc l'unité que nous utilisons pour
faire le bilan radiatif de la
l'atmosphère est des watts par mètre carré nous
aurait pu utiliser juste des watts
puisque l'atmosphère a un contact donné
zone avec le sol qui est connue
qui est la surface d'ici mais dans ce
cas plutôt que
[Musique]
transportant des multiples de watts avec
un 10 à la puissance 12 partout dans le
lieu en fait on préfère y penser
en termes de watts par mètre carré donc
si vous vous souvenez de euh de la dernière
temps ou en fait si vous ne vous souvenez pas
bien parce que peut-être parce que je n'ai pas dit
ce
mais l'ordre de grandeur du solaire
le rayonnement atteignant le sol est de 200
watts par mètre carré c'est un peu
plus que ça mais c'est un écrivain de
grandeur et l'ordre de grandeur de
l'effet de serre naturel est un
un peu moins de 170 watts de mémoire par
mètres carrés et le supplément
effet de serre est de l'ordre de deux
à trois watts par mètre carré
si nous faisons l'effet plus et moins dans
total donc ici vous avez les effets positifs
en particulier
gaz à effet de serre à longue durée de vie
attente ici vous avez tout un tas
des effets
un peu plus ou un peu moins
et ici vous avez les résultats avec le
barre d'air que vous voyez là-bas et vous voyez
que la barre d'air provient principalement du
partie aérosol
d'accord, c'est principalement là que se trouve l'erreur
la barre vient de
donc les effets globaux des humains sur le
les échanges d'énergie entre l'atmosphère
et la surface de la terre est en effet un
effet de forçage positif c'est-à-dire
que nous ajoutons de l'énergie mais vous avez dans le
histoire encore les aérosols qui ont un
effet qui est négatif mais avec un um
avec une magnitude mal évaluée pour un
certain nombre d'entre eux
donc une fois que nous savons que nous avons un réchauffement et
effets de refroidissement, je vais maintenant expliquer les
logique
d'une simulation climatique
la
la logique d'une simulation climatique nécessite
mettre deux choses en entrée de la
simulation il demande de mettre en entrée le
représentation du système physique
donc un modèle climatique et il demande à
mettre en entrée l'hypothèse avec laquelle
nous allons au service physique
système qui consiste à économiser les émissions
donc historiquement et j'ai gardé mon
présentation de cette façon parce que
historiquement c'est comme ça que ça se faisait
et maintenant ça a changé maintenant mais je vais
expliquer comment si historiquement le chemin
qui a été présenté était le suivant
on fait une hypothèse sur les gaz à effet de serre
émissions cette hypothèse est elle-même
conditionnée par des facteurs économiques et autres
hypothèses comme la population, etc.
et cela conduit à avoir la possibilité
trajectoires face à l'avenir
émissions
alors notez une chose importante
c'est ça
dans le scénario d'émission qui en résulte,
les émissions résultent de l'économie qui
provoquer de l'énergie
et donc par rapport à ce que j'ai expliqué à
vous dans la première leçon il y a un
inversion de causalité dans le sens de
faire le scénario puisque normalement vous
avoir de l'énergie et cela vous donne à la fois
les émissions et l'économie d'accord le vrai
l'hypothèse d'entrée n'est pas l'économie qui
causent de l'énergie, mais de l'énergie qui conduit à
valeur économique et émissions et économie
nous devrions donc avoir deux sorties du
même intrant qui sont des émissions de pib non
les émissions en tant que produit du pib est-il
clair ou pas
limpide je suppose que c'est exactement
ce que j'ai expliqué dans la première leçon
cependant les scénarios d'émissions sont faits
par des économistes qui se réfèrent donc
cause et qui vous disent qu'il y a du pib
et que ce PIB demande de l'énergie ou
ils confondent plutôt le facteur limitant
plus précisément ainsi
vous avez des scénarios d'émission et ceux
les émissions montent et descendent ce sont
hypothèses par définition
une fois que tu as des émissions tu mets ça
dans une première étape de modélisation donc là
vous avez déjà la modélisation dans laquelle vous
avoir des évolutions des gaz à effet de serre
concentration
car en fait le forçage réel de la
le climat est l'évolution d'une serre
concentration de gaz si vous avez une augmentation
émissions et qu'en même temps vous
avoir les éviers qui augmentent votre
la concentration ne bouge pas et
il n'y a donc pas de forçage
système climatique pour qu'il y ait un forçage
du système climatique il faut
que l'épaisseur d'une couverture
augmente en fonction de dire la concentration
donc aujourd'hui
dans les rapports qui sont
présenté par le GIEC
ce que vous avez est directement des évolutions sur
la concentration donc quand tu vois rcp
écrit quelque part de nos jours dans
des documents scientifiques qui parlent de
simulations climatiques qui signifie
voie de concentration représentative et
ce sont donc directement les hypothèses qui sont
faite sur l'évolution de la concentration
et de là on tire le possible
scénarios d'émissions
cette évolution de concentration est très
pardonné d'être dévoré par un climat
maquette
et ce modèle climatique dira aïe
plus ou moins fort et ça dira
vous comment ça souffre l'aïe d'accord alors
nous passerons beaucoup de temps aujourd'hui à regarder
ça pour qu'on vous dise que ça chauffe
ça brûle ici ça refroidit là ça
ça fait mal et ici je prends une inondation là-bas un
ouragan bien pour les ouragans c'est un
un peu plus compliqué et ainsi de suite
le modèle climatique vous dira ce qu'il voit
dans l'évolution du système climatique
dans les modèles les plus avancés, il y a maintenant
une rétroaction entre la concentration et
le modèle climatique, par exemple si vous
avoir un climat qui dérive trop vite
de sorte que les écosystèmes ne peuvent pas maintenir une partie de
les choses co2 sont affaiblies et ainsi
les écosystèmes meurent et vous avez donc moins
la photosynthèse et le co2 va moins bien
pris de l'atmosphère et ainsi de suite avec
émissions identiques vous avez le
concentration qui augmente plus
rapidement
d'accord bien ces dépendances
phénomènes sont pris en compte dans
les modèles les plus récents par contre
ce que même les modèles les plus récents ne font pas
prendre en compte et le fera à mon avis
ne tenez jamais compte même de ceux qui
prétendre qu'ils se plaignent auprès du
l'économie est la rétroaction sur l'entrée
hypothèse c'est-à-dire qu'il y a
aucun modèle qui vous indique où
le système climatique a commencé à dériver
rapidement qu'il n'est pas compatible avec
le fait que nous maintenons le courant
pib
d'accord il n'y a pas un seul climat
modèle qui vous dit qu'avec donc
cette particularité ou cette euh cette bizarrerie
disons qui est que les simulations
qui vous donnent le plus désagréable
résultats en matière de réchauffement climatique
aller avec l'émission la plus importante
scénarios
qui, dans la façon dont ils sont écrits aujourd'hui
va aussi avec l'économie qui va
le meilleur
donc nous avons quelque chose d'un peu surprenant
c'est-à-dire que plus le climat
le système se détériore, mieux c'est
économie c'est ce que tu as
chronologiquement de la manière que euh
aujourd'hui les simulations sont faites
je répète ou c'est clair
d'accord
nous avons besoin des émissions les plus importantes
l'économie dans le magasin est dit que c'est
faire au mieux pour que le climat devienne
pire qui est une autre façon de dire
que le climat ne peut jamais faire obstacle
que les simulations sont faites endommagent le
système économique par construction
d'accord
donc quelles seront les émissions est évidemment
impossible de prédire je ne sais pas comment
prédire combien d'hommes il y aura dans
40 ans, je ne sais pas comment prédire comment
combien d'huile il y aura par personne ou combien
beaucoup de gaz ou de charbon par personne je ne sais pas
comment prédire combien les gens vont manger
viande par personne tout ce que je peux dire c'est
que si c'est terriblement différent de
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui c'est mauvais
la catastrophe aura déjà pris en charge
réguler rapidement le système qui est le
la seule chose que je peux dire mais sinon je
Je ne peux pas le prédire alors ce que font les gens
que font les simulations, c'est que puisqu'elles ne le font pas
savent bien prédire qu'ils le font
scénarios
donc ils prennent plusieurs possibilités et
dans ce que je vais vous montrer à partir de maintenant
sur les résultats sera toujours
conditionné à l'hypothèse
qui a été prise en entrée
d'accord donc
encore une fois c'est quelque chose d'essentiel
il faut comprendre que les résultats
que vous verrez désormais sont toujours
conditionné aux émissions
et donc
puisque je pense que je ne donnerai pas la même chose
examen encore cette année l'une des raisons
pourquoi il est impossible de prévoir
avec précision les risques du changement climatique
c'est notamment parce qu'il est impossible de
prévoir avec précision les émissions
sera
j'ai posé la question à tes amis
l'année dernière pourquoi est-il impossible de
prévoir avec précision les risques climatiques
changer et je pense qu'un seul sur cinq
les copies que j'ai déjà réussi à
correct qui a réussi à obtenir que c'était
parce que les émissions ne sont pas
prévisible là donc soit l'autre
quatre dormaient ou ils n'étaient pas dans
bonne forme ce jour-là mais là donc depuis
nous ne pouvons pas prédire les émissions que nous allons
ne jamais être en mesure de prédire avec précision
conséquences d'accord
alors voici quelle perspective de la
première étape d'une modélisation donne ceci
c'est à dire
passer des émissions à la concentration
encore une fois je vous rappelle que de nos jours nous
reculent donc
d'abord nous avons le rcp et à partir de là nous
tirer la tradition possible
trajectoires et émissions voici comment
c'est fait de nos jours
et donc vous avez ici
donc une perspective de
concentration ici en fait le plus
important d'entre eux co2 dans l'air
nous avons celui que vous aviez avant nous
commencé à jouer avec la combustion interne
moteurs et machines à vapeur
celui qui a commencé à
se déformer jusqu'à la fin du 20ème siècle
et ici vous avez le possible
évolutions au cours du XXIe siècle, mais
vous voyez que ces évolutions possibles
sont très différents selon les
scénarios d'émissions
donc le scénario bas jusqu'à présent je le prends
comme euh émissions qui restent constantes donc
en fait je devrais euh je devrais
vous présenter via le 1,5 degré
scénario disons
en fait le scénario de 1,5 degré
en gros c'est ce qu'on a déjà émis
donc si
ce ne sont pas les émissions qui resteront
constant ce sont les émissions qui vont à zéro
demain matin c'est le 1,5 degré
scénario
pour
des émissions qui restent constantes jusqu'à
à des émissions fortement augmentées
donc jusqu'à maintenant j'avais l'habitude d'appeler ça le
polonais du scénario de l'an 2000 alors pourquoi
vernis de l'an 2000 car la piscine
c'est l'européen qui s'en remet encore
la plupart sur le charbon
en proportion
et
ce qu'il reste à extraire de la
le sol est avant tout du charbon et de plus
à partir de l'an 2000 parce que ce scénario
correspond à l'efficacité
consommation de 10 milliards de terriens qui
utiliserait le même montant par personne de
l'énergie comme la piscine aujourd'hui
c'est pourquoi je l'ai appelé comme ça
et cela aide à visualiser dans les réseaux sociaux
termes économiques la signification d'un tel
scénario d'émissions donc en fait c'est seulement
signifie une humanité de 10 milliards
personnes qui considèrent que ce qui est
acceptable ce qui est normal ce qui est
la norme disons est de vivre comme un
piscine d'un an à jeûner si on a ça
tant en termes de consommation d'énergie que
performance technique on arrive à un
scénario d'émission qui vous donne ceci
concentration de co2 à la fin du 21
siècle pour vous donner une idée
alors
une fois qu'on a une évolution du co2
concentration
nous l'avons ensuite mis dans un modèle climatique afin
qu'est-ce qu'un modèle climatique c'est un modèle virtuel
planète au lieu d'être un simulateur de vol
c'est un simulateur climatique
et cette planète virtuelle qui est
donc une maquette numérique qui tourne sur
un ordinateur est nécessairement un discret
modèle parce que vous savez que même très
les ordinateurs puissants n'aiment pas infiniti
tout ce qu'ils peuvent faire, c'est gérer un nombre fini
nombre d'opérations ou un nombre fini
de points oui
Je veux dire qu'on peut toujours trouver pire
scénarios je veux dire qu'il n'y a pas de problème je suis
juste dire que celui-ci en fait
correspond à un sondage de l'an 2000
appliqué à 10 milliards de personnes
je veux dire j'ai choisi que c'est pour illustrer
car puisque tu as encore aujourd'hui un
niveau de vie supérieur à
celle d'un sondage
donc ce que je dis c'est que si 10 milliards
les terriens veulent vivre un peu moins bien
plus que toi c'est ce que ça donne
termes de scénario d'émission ou plutôt à
le niveau de confort matériel que vous
il faut aujourd'hui être plus précis et cela
est ce qu'il représente en termes de
émissions et donc en termes de
concentration c'était pour illustrer que
donc je disais qu'un modèle climatique est un
représentation numérique d'une planète c'est
un modèle et donc par construction c'est
quelque chose de discret
donc il y a des grains
donc la façon dont cela fonctionne est que nous découpons
tous les compartiments fluides de la planète
dans des boîtes à chaussures c'est-à-dire dans
têtes de tuyaux parallèles ou presque parce que
ils sont un peu courbés mais ce sont
les pipettes parallèles pour clowns sont faites pour
les personnes aux pieds très plats car
typiquement la longueur sur l'horizontale
est de quelques dixièmes à cent kilomètres
donc on va dire 100 kilomètres en commandes
de magnitude et sur la verticale le
l'épaisseur est plutôt de 100 mètres donc c'est
pieds très très plats mais sinon c'est
l'idée qu'on va couper le
l'atmosphère et l'océan en boîtes à chaussures
et nous irons jusqu'au sol
concernés y sont représentés avec des grilles
ainsi qu'avec des propriétés d'échange qui
avec l'ambiance qui est différente
selon qu'il s'agit d'eau ou de lentille
évidemment
ces modèles ont été sophistiqués
au fil du temps, mais tous sont basés sur la base
équations de la physique et une importante
chose qui peut surprendre au premier abord
parce qu'on se dit hey c'est
pas la façon dont nous faisons habituellement des expériences
mais une chose qui est très importante pour
savoir est que ce que nous regardons avec ces
modèles est la façon dont ils convergent avec une donnée
concentrations de gaz à effet de serre et comment
i cela ne dépend pas de l'état initial
avec lequel nous les paramétrons dans d'autres
mots ces modèles si la moyenne
température à votre 0 est soit 15 16 soit
17 degrés c'est pas le point en fait quoi
nous allons voir comment ils
converger dans le temps avec ce que nous avons
donné
comme euh comme une évolution
sur la quantité de gaz à effet de serre
dans l'ambiance
donc ces modèles se sont améliorés avec le temps
les premières choses
ils ont fait était la taille de la grille parce que dans
fait qu'ils s'améliorent
comme la puissance de calcul disponible
augmente fondamentalement vous savez que
traditionnellement, les organisations météorologiques sont
parmi les acheteurs de supercalculateurs
les gens qui aiment les ordinateurs avec très
grande puissance sont des gens qui font n'importe qui
et en ce qui concerne les modèles climatiques
ils fonctionnent avec une partie atmosphérique qui
est exactement celle du temps donc le
les notes ne sont pas aussi fines mais elles sont les
mêmes équations
la
quatre acronymes ou les quatre lettres qui
vous avez ici sont représentatifs de la
quatre premiers rapports d'évaluation du GIEC
so f pour le premier rapport d'évaluation s pour
deuxième t pour troisième et puisque nous avons déjà
utilisé f pour la première fois nous ne l'avons pas réutilisé pour
quatrième donc nous mettons un r quatre
parce que nous totalisons les ventes que les gens peuvent
les confondre ce n'est pas complètement
impossible ce que vous voyez sont deux choses
d'abord la taille de la grille a très
clairement diminué et la deuxième chose
vous voyez, c'est que la topographie est apparue
c'est-à-dire qu'au départ le terrain
était plat et en fait ce qui était
différencié était l'eau et la terre et sur
atterrir ce que vous aviez de la végétation et
terres non couvertes qui ont été différenciées
mais il n'a pas été différencié en termes
du cycle du carbone, il s'agissait principalement
différenciée en termes d'albédo qui
c'est-à-dire le pouvoir réfléchissant de la
surface
et puis tu vois qu'avec le temps on fait
le terrain apparaît c'est-à-dire qu'on apporte un
capacité à se différencier en altitude
ce qui occupe un maillage de grille
si c'est l'atmosphère si c'est le sol
Nous avons également
oui
non non c'est lié au fait que sur
le premier que tu vois c'est plat
ah ouais en effet il y a un petit truc dessus
le droit si vous voulez disons que euh
ah oui en effet à gauche il y a
topographie oh excuse moi
mais c'est la topographie qui reste euh
très grossier
mais tu as raison
la
deuxième chose
c'est arrivé avec euh en ce qui concerne le
modèles, c'est qu'au fil du temps, ils ont
deviennent plus complexes en ce qui concerne
processus qui sont pris en compte afin
au moment de la
le de la première génération de modèles
disons qu'ils étaient surtout atmosphériques
et le reste des compartiments du
planète n'est pas apparue et donc le
les échanges avec l'océan étaient
paramétré par exemple qui est là
il n'y avait pas de dynamique océanique l'océan a été vu
comme surface d'échange avec une planète et
les échanges ont été paramétrés
puis comme des générations de modèles
amélioré vous commencez à avoir de plus en plus
compartiments qui apparaissent
alors
tu as une notion
vous avez
végétation l'océan commence à devenir
dynamique vous avez les aérosols et maintenant dans
les modèles les plus récents
vous avez la plupart de ce qui se passe dans le
atmosphère
ou plutôt dans la terre pour être plus
précis donc dans l'atmosphère et
dans l'océan
vous voyez évidemment les nuages ​​couvrir cela
est apparu maintenant il y a de l'atmosphère
chimie vous avez un cycle du carbone etc
vous avez la plupart des processus majeurs
qui sont représentés
quelque chose d'intéressant à noter en passant
est que l'amélioration de ces modèles
pas une seule fois n'a jamais fondamentalement
changé les ordres de grandeur de la
élévation de température résultant de
l'augmentation donnée de la concentration de co2
dans l'ambiance tout simplement parce que
cette élévation de température se traduit au
première commande à partir du montant de l'extra
l'énergie envoyée au sol par
cet effet de serre supplémentaire et
qui vient d'un assez bien compris
processus physique d'absorption
réémission par un gaz d'accord
et une fois que vous avez le montant total de
l'énergie revenant au sol et que
tu sais diviser ce qui est
observé par l'océan et ce qui est
absorbé par le sol au premier ordre
vous avez assez facilement votre élévation et
température du sol
alors le
la sophistication des modèles fait
permet de mieux approcher un certain
nombre de phénomènes locaux notamment
il permet d'améliorer la
résolution spatiale de ce qui va
arriver par contre ça ne se fait pas
changement à la première commande j'insiste le
conséquences globales disons de quoi
se produira et en particulier le
augmentation de la température moyenne
qui représente l'augmentation de la quantité de
énergie contenue dans le système
les modèles climatiques comme tous les modèles
lorsqu'il est utilisé par des personnes qui connaissent à peu près
ce qu'ils font
la première chose que nous faisons une fois que nous avons
les a développés est de les tester sur le
passé
quand vous avez un modèle la première chose
vous faites pour vérifier que cela fonctionne est de
le confronter à ce qui s'est passé
avant de
et d'ailleurs il n'y en a pas un seul
modèle économique qui passe ce genre de
faire de l'exercice avec succès sauf si vous
modifier les paramètres que vous recherchez pour
assurez-vous que ça colle mais sinon
ça ne marche pas comme pour le physique
les modèles c'est exactement comme ça
calibré
et donc c'est exactement comme ça qu'on calibre
les modèles climatiques
ce que vous voyez ici est euh
oh et comme dans n'importe quel tableau de l'ipcc il y a un
beaucoup d'informations
c'est ainsi qu'un ensemble de modèles
si je me souviens bien il y a environ
20 là-dedans
comment ils se comparent à ce qui a été
observé en ce qui concerne l'évolution de
Température
donc en ce qui concerne l'évolution de
températures que vous avez sur chacun de ces
graphiques qui représentent soit comme un
région comme ici ou dans le monde entier
de terres émergées ou d'océan comme ici-bas
eh bien tu as
ce que ces modèles vous disent
quand on les laisse évoluer avec
modification des gaz à effet de serre qui a
vraiment été c'est la courbe rose vous
avoir en noir ce que les mesures réelles
de températures vous a donné voir
partout et donc ce que vous voyez est que
avec quelques anomalies
à cette époque par exemple sur l'océan
et donc ces anomalies sont aussi sur
le graphique global ici
bien
vous avez quelque chose qui modélise
reproduisent assez bien les tendances générales
sur la variation des températures sur
la période
alors les mêmes modélistes se sont amusés à regarder
quel est le modèle qui reproduit quoi
arrivé aurait donné si le
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre n'avaient pas augmenté
et ça te donne bien la courbe bleue
plus exactement l'enveloppe bleue
donc l'enveloppe bleue est l'enveloppe de
toutes les simulations qui sont faites dans un
modèle climatique
dans un monde virtuel où l'homme n'a pas
émis des gaz à effet de serre et à ce
point vous voyez que les températures globales
rester à peu près constant
d'accord, le système est à peu près
écurie
alors que quand tu mets les gaz à effet de serre
émissions le système dérive
là donc ce genre de test c'est quelque chose
absolument indispensable pour crédibiliser
à ces outils numériques pour ce qu'ils
nous dira pour plus tard
je ne l'apporte pas aujourd'hui mais tu le feras
trouver sur internet pour ceux d'entre vous
qui va voir
euh des simulations et dans ce cas en vrai
temps
de ces modèles climatiques qui simulent
vrf vu de l'atmosphère
et donc il y a une comparaison entre
images satellites réelles d'un côté
et une représentation avec un numérique
modèle de l'autre
et quand tu compares les deux alors prends le
test avec quelqu'un en double aveugle
ne peut généralement pas dire lequel est lequel tout
bon donc aujourd'hui il y a
aussi une qualité de représentation qui
est extrêmement bon en ce qui concerne
capacité de ces modèles à visuellement
représente euh
[Musique]
représenter le système
alors nous parlerons de l'avenir avec
ces modèles
une fois euh ils ont pu retracer
le passé
ce que vous avez ici est à nouveau un graphique qui
est
du dernier puits le dernier grand ipcc
rapport tellement désolé l'avant dernier euh 2007
pas 2013 mais vraiment pas vraiment
changer beaucoup dans le dernier
l'intérêt de ce graphique est qu'il
discrimine très précisément le chemin
dont la température peut évoluer
selon le scénario d'émissions
c'est l'idée qu'il faut avoir en tête
ce que vous avez ici est l'évolution de
la température au 20ème siècle
vous remarquez que le changement de
température au cours du 20ème siècle est
déjà une fraction de degré qui a
été acquise et ensuite la manière dont
la température évolue dans le futur
selon les hypothèses qui sont
réalisé sur les émissions de gaz à effet de serre
l'hypothèse la plus basse dans ces
simulations
c'est que la concentration reste
constant
ce qui veut dire qu'essentiellement
les émissions commencent à diminuer très
très rapidement
euh
à partir de demain matin
et ils deviennent nuls bien avant la fin
du siècle donc là en effet tu vois
que nous pouvons maintenir les 1,5degrés
là, nous avons un diplôme d'accord, nous
ont commencé à peu près à partir de là et donc
on tient les 1,5 degrés dit autrement
pour maintenir les émissions de 1,5 degrés doit
commencer à diminuer très rapidement à partir
demain
et être nul bien avant la fin de la
siècle c'est ce que cela signifie
maintenez pour maintenir les 1,5 degrés
et euh
et euh ouais on n'est pas parti pour une bonne
commencer à le faire après que vous avez
ici un scénario dans lequel nous gardons
des émissions constantes, c'est essentiellement un
scénario et donc ce que vous voyez ici est
qu'il s'agit d'un scénario dans lequel nous gagnons
deux degrés par rapport à 1990 que vous
avoir ici
mais on gagne presque gratuitement
par rapport à l'ère préindustrielle tout
droit
donc ce que vous avez là est un scénario
c'est presque trois degrés ce que vous voyez
voici l'enveloppe pour ce scénario
de toutes les simulations
l'enveloppe de tous les modèles dans d'autres
mots les 20 modèles utilisés avec le même
scénario le plus conservateur vous dit
nous gagnerons un degré par rapport à 1990
et les plus pessimistes vous disent que nous
gagnera trois degrés par rapport à
1990.
ce que ce graphique donc donc
vous dit, c'est qu'il y a encore un
variabilité liée aux hypothèses
qui sont faites dans le modèle parce que même
ou
car entre tous les modèles que tu fais
pas exactement les mêmes options que
sont pris pour toujours la représentation d'un
certain nombre de processus ou plus
exactement pour les valeurs prises pour
paramètres ou pour la frontière
conditions d'un certain nombre de
processus parce que vous avez des choses qui
reste paramétré là-dedans donc
selon le modèle
et parce qu'évidemment les paramètres que nous
essayez de les ajuster désolé selon
observations passées c'est ainsi que nous
essayer constamment de recalibrer le modèle
donc selon le modèle utilisé
vous voyez que vous avez toujours une barre d'erreur
qui est de l'ordre de deux degrés sur
ce scénario sur la température
augmentation que vous avez à la fin
donc nous ne sommes pas
tout à fait dans l'épaisseur d'une ligne parce que
vous verrez que les conséquences
concernant ou
ou liées au changement climatique ne sont pas au
tout de même à plus un et je plus
trois degrés
le scénario intermédiaire ici est un
scénario qui est um considéré au moins
comme un scénario cool haut de gamme au moins dans
mon jargon c'est le double des émissions
et tu y vois bien toujours pareil
ce qui correspond à ce scénario est
là et donc dans ce scénario ici là
est une version basse qui passe à 1.5 et un
version haute qui passe à plus de 4
degrés donc très souvent il y a une erreur
fait face à ce genre de
l'incertitude c'est-à-dire que si
il y a beaucoup d'incertitude
sur le fait que nous sommes en grande
danger et j'attendrai d'en savoir plus pour
soyez sûr que c'est vraiment un grand danger
donc le parallèle que je vais faire
c'est que si un de tes potes un jour
après avoir beaucoup bu vous demande de traverser
célibataires à cinq heures du matin
les yeux bandés
ivre je pense qu'il y a un super
l'incertitude quant à savoir si vous allez
mourir ou pas je ne suis pas tout à fait sûr que
tu vas le faire
donc en fait une grande incertitude est
représentant au contraire d'un
grand risque
s'il y a une grande incertitude, cela signifie
que je ne suis pas en mesure de vous donner un supérieur
lié à ce que vous risquez
d'accord
donc l'idée qu'une grande incertitude est un
excellente police d'assurance qui signifie que
il est urgent de ne rien faire c'est l'exact
contraire d'une conclusion qui doit être
une grande incertitude est un grand risque
un très gros risque
et enfin mon scénario polonais
euh c'est un scénario
comme vous pouvez le voir, cela peut nous emmener au-delà
six degrés avec une génération de modèles
qui a été utilisé à l'époque alors maintenant nous
disent généralement que c'est pour toujours cinq mais
cela ne change pas vraiment grand-chose
conclusions que vous en tirez
donc tu comprends donc ici
que vous avez une fois de plus une dispersion
lié au modèle utilisé pour um
pour le même scénario
une autre façon de présenter la même chose
est-ce
quand tu fais une simulation
en fait nous
peut aussi faire une simulation
nous pouvons faire des choses en fait nous pouvons oui
non c'est comparé à 1850
et donc il y a déjà un degré qui
a été gagné
et donc fondamentalement les émissions doivent
aller à zéro demain matin donc ouais
fondamentalement
alors
concernant euh comment comprendre ça
je vais vous le montrer d'une autre manière
pour le même modèle
tu peux faire
plusieurs simulations
avec de petits changements de paramètres dans le
maquette
et bien sûr à chaque fois ça donnera
vous une valeur légèrement différente de sorte que vous êtes
va avoir une distribution des résultats
et vous considérez que la valeur que
vous allez garder est le haut de la
gaussien si jamais vos résultats sont
distribué à peu près comme un normal
Distribution
ou vous pouvez aussi considérer que
pour une famille de modèles
vous regarderez en haut de la
gaussiennes pour chacun des modèles et
faites une moyenne de tout cela et considérez
que c'est ce que tu vas garder
comme la valeur de votre multi-modèle
simulation ce qu'on appelle multi-ensemble
entre spécialistes donc en fait quand c'est
être compris avec tout ce discours
sur les simulations et c'est une autre façon
de dire exactement la même chose, c'est que
quand on vous dit pour un scénario donné
des émissions le réchauffement que nous obtenons
c'est tellement en fait ça devrait être
compris que c'est tellement
la valeur la plus probable
d'une distribution qui ressemble à un
gaussien
ce n'est donc pas un moyen de garantir qu'il
ne peut pas être plus
est-ce clair
ce n'est pas une façon de garantir qu'il
ne peut pas être plus
ce qui est intéressant avec la montée en
température que nous allons avoir ou
ce qui est essentiel plus exactement non seulement
intéressant est de confronter cela à la
passé pourquoi
imaginez que je prends un être vivant
et que je vous raconte cet être vivant je
augmentera sa température de 4
degrés
et je vous demande est-ce un problème ou est-ce
Pas de problème
ben je vais te dire ça dépend ça devrait
prendre un poisson rouge
ceux d'entre vous qui auront un jour des enfants
vos enfants pourraient un jour réclamer une
poisson rouge et en ce moment vous trouverez
que le poisson rouge doit venir
en vacances, etc. et vous êtes donc dans
hâte que le poisson rouge meure parce que
de cette façon, vous serez libéré des tracas
alors
vous pouvez essayer de tuer le poisson rouge pour donner
c'est un peu plus froid de l'eau un peu plus chaude
l'eau, etc., puis vous verrez que le
le poisson rouge se porte comme un charme
votre désespoir et pourquoi cela parce que le
le poisson rouge est un animal à sang froid
et donc le poisson rouge si vous infligez un
élévation de température de quatre degrés jusqu'à
l'eau dans laquelle il erre il ne va pas
s'en fou il continue d'être très bien
là et tu dois encore vivre avec
son aquarium
si vous infligez donc à certains animaux
une variation de leur intérieur
température de 4 degrés qui vraiment
ne les dérange vraiment pas du tout, donc ça
n'a pas d'importance
si je prends un animal à sang chaud comme toi
par exemple si j'inflige un changement de
votre température interne de quatre
degrés j'attends juste un peu et tu es
mort donc quatre degrés de plus c'est grave
docteur
pour le système climatique, la réponse est
exactement pareil ça dépend du
variation spontanée du système lorsque
il est laissé à lui-même si nous réalisons que
le système seul varie de quatre
degrés d'une semaine à l'autre, il est
n'a vraiment pas d'importance que l'action de
hommes provoque un réchauffement de quatre degrés
puisqu'il relève de la nature
variabilité d'un système de sorte qu'il ne
importe pas du tout de faire ça de l'autre
part si la variabilité naturelle d'un
système n'est pas de quatre degrés tous les
l'autre jour, à ce stade, il devient très
ennuyeux parce que cela signifie que nous
infliger une déstabilisation qui est
sans précédent et il y aura donc
être des conséquences sans précédent afin de
répondre à la question concernant la
système climatique, nous devons être capables de
reconstruire la manière dont il a
varié dans le passé
et donc il y a maintenant tout un domaine de
science qui s'appelle la paléoclimatologie
qui sert à cela comme à dire quel
est utilisé pour reconstituer les variations de
les températures dans le passé il y a
deux grandes familles de techniques de
faire cela ou libérer les familles nombreuses plus
exactement et à chaque fois c'est la science
d'une houe nous devons faire des trous
une première façon de faire des trous est de faire
trous dans les arbres
et si possible dans de très vieux arbres et
comme ça
nous mesurerons l'épaisseur et la
dureté des cernes des arbres qui obtiennent
agrégé année après année dans le coffre
et savez-vous quel âge a le plus ancien
l'arbre vivant est
aujourd'hui
deux mille qui dit mieux
sept cents qui dit mieux
quatre mille donc c'est encore un peu
plus que ça c'est sept mille
il y a un pin dans
ce sont donc des arbres qui vivent généralement
dans des zones soumises à des conditions extrêmes
pour la vie donc c'est comme la neige en antarctique
ce sont des choses qui augmentent extrêmement
peu chaque année dans un très très lent
métabolisme et je crois que c'est un
pin de californie et une zone semi-désertique
ou quelque chose comme ça
dans ce coffre on peut faire un trou et ainsi
nous avons sept mille ans de climat
archives et donc le problème est que nous
n'avons pas d'archives globales nous n'avons que
archives climatiques partout où les arbres poussent et
de plus l'arbre ne pousse pas dans
hiver alors qu'est-ce que les archives vous donnent
c'est nous nous pouvons avec ça
reconstituer les températures et les
précipitations de la saison de croissance qui est
printemps et été et à partir de là nous
ont déjà un proxy pour voir comment le
système climatique évolue dans son ensemble sur
l'année
les arbres que vous avez peut-être remarqués comme moi
ce
ils ne poussent pas beaucoup sur l'eau donc ça
méthode fonctionne bien pour reconstruire
températures terrestres
donc dès que vous avez accès aux arbres
ou pour fossiliser des troncs d'arbres que vous êtes
capable de dater correctement
alors vous avez accès à une technique
appelée dendrochronologie qui vous permet
pour reconstituer les températures du passé
encore une fois ces températures du
ravageurs sont reconstruits avec un modèle
ce qui permet de passer de
données d'observation l'épaisseur et
dureté d'un cerne d'arbre à un observé
température ou dans un
température plus exactement
et vous avez les modèles qui vous permettent
pour faire ça
qui ont encore une fois une spécificité
paramétrage de sorte que chaque
chercheur qui fait ce genre de choses
ce genre d'analyse
publie ses propres résultats et vous
avons ici une compilation qui a été re
publié dans le rapport 2007 du GIEC en
dont vous avez toutes les offres qui sont
ici qui
ont chacun publié une reconstitution de
les températures du nord
hémisphère
car c'est le plus équipé let's
dire dans
superficie du terrain
au cours du dernier millénaire
et donc ce que vous voyez au cours de la dernière
millénaire est qu'il y a deux points
de convergence dans ces analyses
c'est d'abord que tout le monde dit qu'autour
l'an 1000 plus ou moins c'était un
peu plus chaud par rapport au reste de
le millénaire
alors
c'est un peu plus chaud toute l'année
1000 est connu comme le médiéval
optimale donc il y a quelque chose qui
devrait vous intéresser pendant le médiéval
l'optimum est qu'il y en avait un dans
l'angleterre donc parce que le vin vous intéresse
beaucoup et dans les autres conséquences
que euh qu'on avait à ce moment là
c'est que les vikings ont sorti leur
dépliants publicitaires et dit aller à
le groenland c'est tout vert et en fait toi
connaître le groenland
alors qu'il fait très froid
cela signifie droit de territoire vert
alors
l'histoire qui est une histoire qui est
souvent pris par le changement climatique
des négateurs pour dire regarde le climat il y a
naturellement il fut un temps où
le groenland était tout vert et ainsi de suite
évidemment le groenland n'était pas tout vert
il y a mille ans c'était pareil
calotte glaciaire qu'aujourd'hui sur le Groenland sur le
d'autre part tu avais une frange du groenland
où
tu n'as pas d'yeux c'est d'ailleurs
où vivent des esquimaux intérieurs et des cygnes
tu as des berges rocheuses
et ainsi de suite ces endroits où vous n'avez pas
avoir de la glace il y a mille ans comme
tu n'en as pas aujourd'hui la croissance
la saison de l'herbe a été un peu plus longue que
c'est aujourd'hui et nous soupçonnons donc
vikings de s'être débarrassés de quelques
des gens qu'ils ne voulaient plus voir
les envoyant là-bas avec des femmes de troupeaux et
enfants ou vous pouvez lire l'histoire dans
Le livre de Jack Jared Diamond intitulé
s'effondrer donc il y a un certain nombre de choses
qui sont discutables dans ce livre mais
je pense d'autre part que c'est
assez bien dit et je pense que c'est joli
corriger
alors on y a envoyé 5000 vikings avec leurs
troupeaux et quand le climat s'est refroidi
après l'optimum médiéval bien
vous voyez que la saison de croissance de l'herbe
a décliné et ainsi les vaches sont mortes et ainsi
les vikings parce qu'ils ne voulaient pas
commencer à manger du phoque et donc ils ne l'ont pas fait
comme ça culturellement
et donc les analyses convergent pour vous dire
ce
et tu vois qu'après ça refroidit
en bas et là tu vois qu'on est à
quelque chose qu'on appelle le petit âge glaciaire
europe les canaux les canaux en
l'inclusion se fige complètement dans le
l'hiver
nous mourons de froid euh le marquis
de sévigny allume du feu en août et
sûr que c'est fou et c'est d'ailleurs à
ce moment que la révolution le
révolution française a lieu et vous
sache que la révolution française est née
après une grande famine qui a eu lieu en
la france qui a tué entre cinq cents
mille et un million de personnes d'accord
et c'est donc un temps où les moissons
ne sont pas bons
donc ça pose problème
parce que euh les gens n'aiment pas avoir un
l'estomac vide
ce que vous voyez aussi dans le troisième
convergence de toutes ces choses est que
du début de l'ère industrielle
fissure
toutes les analyses vous disent qu'il
commence à monter rapidement
donc la première conclusion que nous pouvons tirer
de cette analyse à l'échelle de la
millénaire
c'est que nous sommes déjà ici dans un
décalage de température qui est totalement hors
de tendance avec et qui va beaucoup
plus rapide que n'importe quelle tendance que vous pouvez voir
donc je parle de tendances pas annuelles
variations mais les tendances que vous pouvez
réellement identifier à partir de cela, donc
après on peut rentrer
plus loin dans le temps
alors euh
je te montrerai je te montrerai plus tard mais euh
on peut y remonter sur ce graphique jusqu'à
60 millions d'années
et donc si nous regardons 60 millions d'années
ce que nous voyons, c'est que depuis ce temps et
alors attention le cadeau est ici sur le
à gauche et le passé est là à droite
nous voyons ce qui s'est passé
est globalement un refroidissement lent du climat
système
et ce lent refroidissement du climat
système est notamment allé avec un
diminution importante de la quantité de
co2 dans l'atmosphère
donc sur des échelles de temps très très longues
en effet le climat a eu tendance à plutôt
refroidir
ce que tu vois aussi c'est que ça fait longtemps
il y a quelque temps le climat était de près de 10
degrés de plus qu'aujourd'hui
donc le fait que le climat soit plus chaud
qu'aujourd'hui n'est pas nécessairement quelque chose
c'est une première dans l'histoire planétaire
par contre c'est quoi une premiere
l'histoire interplanétaire est que
et ce que nous allons détailler à partir de
maintenant est une variation de cette ampleur
appliqué à une humanité sédentaire de 7 ou
10 milliards d'hommes bons d'accord c'est nouveau
et s'il y a eu à grande échelle
variations dans le passé à aucun moment à
du moins en ce qui nous concerne ont
ils ont empêché notre espèce de
en développement depuis que nous sommes ici
d'autre part entre ne pas nuire
l'espèce et ne nuisant à aucun
représentatif de l'espèce il y a un
petite différence
autrement dit si le climat actuel
le changement ne laisse que 5 millions d'hommes bons
vivant c'est plus que suffisant pour assurer
la perpétuation d'une espèce
ça ne pose pas de problème pour
perpétuation d'une espèce
alors
l'objet
que nous verrons à partir de maintenant n'est pas si
l'humanité va traverser beaucoup
et je peux déjà vous donner la réponse à
ce qui est oui c'est peut-on avoir un
idée dans quelles conditions et combien de
eux et ce sont des questions qui demeurent
sans réponse
je
alors
je vais maintenant présenter un plus récent
variation de température que celle qui
s'est passé il y a 65 millions d'années
avec euh
cette petite carte
qui représente
ou plutôt deux cartes qui représentent l'europe
ici vous avez une représentation schématique
des écosystèmes qui sont donc les
reflet d'un système climatique car
le reflet d'un système climatique est
les écosystèmes installés les écosystèmes
installé en europe aujourd'hui si nous ne le faisons pas
retirez-les pour bien faire essentiellement
des champs mais aussi des routes des usines des ponts
voies ferrées depuis cette université
bien si nous ne supprimons pas les écosystèmes pour
faire que nous avons en europe essentiellement
forêts cela signifie que le climat est
assez humide pour que les grandes espèces végétales puissent
grandir
et qu'en plus il ne fait jamais trop froid
ni trop chaud pour que le métabolisme de
ces espèces ne sont pas euh gênées
voila à quoi ressemblait l'europe 20 000
il y a des années donc il y a vingt mille ans
dans l'évolution du quaternaire nous
sont au cœur de la dernière période glaciaire et
donc il fait beaucoup plus froid qu'aujourd'hui sinon
ce ne serait pas une période glaciaire
bientôt vous verrez de combien
et comme il fait beaucoup plus froid qu'aujourd'hui
paysage de la planète n'est pas tout le
même et le paysage de l'europe n'est pas
tout de même la première chose que vous
peut voir, c'est que vous pouvez oublier
Erasmus en Suède puisqu'il n'y a pas
suédois il n'y a pas de danois il n'y a pas
nageoires et il n'y a même pas de nord
allemands et il n'y a pas d'écossais donc
c'est bien pour les rugbymen mais alors
toutes ces personnes sont de bonnes personnes
sous la glace donc vous avez un énorme trois
kilomètre fausse calotte glaciaire qui recouvre le
toute la scandinavie donc pour ceux d'entre vous
qui comme eux il n'y a pas de québécois
soit puisque tout le canada est aussi
sous la glace pour qu'il n'y ait pas de sables bitumineux
bonnes nouvelles
vous avez une énorme calotte glaciaire encore plus grande que
celui sur la scandinavie qui se trouve sur
Canada
cette glace est constituée d'eau pour les jeunes
ingénieurs que vous êtes nerveux
et cette eau devait être prélevée
quelque part donc il n'y a clairement pas assez
l'eau ni dans les lacs ni dans les
les rivières ni dans l'atmosphère pour faire
autant de glace donc le seul endroit où
vous pouvez prendre autant d'eau pour faire
autant de glace c'est la mer et depuis le
mer est une grande baignoire dont le fond a
pas bien changé si vous prenez de l'eau pour
faire toute cette glace le niveau de l'eau baisse
et le niveau d'eau est inférieur de 120
mètres donc il n'y a pas non plus d'indice de navigation
tasse depuis le canal de bristol donc tu oublies
le parrainage pour faire de la voile et toi
peut enfin s'occuper de sérieux
problèmes juste pour plaisanter
donc le point bas d'un canal c'est aujourd'hui
est de 114 mètres et depuis le niveau de l'eau
est inférieur de 120 il n'y a plus de canal
alors pour ceux qui en ont entendu parler
vous pouvez également entrer dans les grottes de koskir sur
sol sec je ne sais pas si tu sais
où la cave costco est bien le costco
grotte est une grotte dont l'entrée est maintenant
submergé et qui se trouve dans le
méditerranéen donc ça veut dire que
il faut descendre 30 mètres sous le
niveau d'eau pour entrer dans la grotte et à l'intérieur
vous avez un puits ascendant et la grotte
est conservé avec les peintures etc comme
à lasko et viscay aujourd'hui son entrée
est submergé et cela signifie qu'au
le temps qu'il était habité on pouvait y entrer
terre aride car manifestement préhistorique
les hommes n'avaient pas de scaphandres autonomes
et donc le niveau d'eau était beaucoup plus bas
le climat était beaucoup plus froid
donc il y avait beaucoup moins d'évaporation et
donc c'était beaucoup plus sec
et dans ce bien plus froid et plus sec
climat la végétation installée dans
L'Europe 
ressemblait plus à ce que nous avons aujourd'hui
nord de la sibérie
donc ce n'est pas très luxuriant d'accord le
champs de blé scintillants d'aujourd'hui et
la forêt scintillante de fontainebleau
ne sont pas vraiment là
et dans ce genre d'écosystème
nous avons réussi à soutenir cent mille
bons hommes c'est-à-dire cent
mille animaux à la fin d'un aliment
chaîne et c'est à peu près l'humain
population de l'époque alors vous voyez que c'est
même pas le nombre d'élèves en prépa
cours je pense que ce n'est sûrement pas le
nombre d'étudiants en ingénierie supérieure
la période des écoles donc vous voyez que c'est un petit
personnel la population française de l'époque
donc à gauche
l'europe à l'ère glaciaire à droite
L'Europe d'aujourd'hui donc je répète quand tu pars
du paysage à gauche vers le
paysage sur la droite vous avez un global
sommes-nous d'accord
eh bien ce réchauffement est historiquement de cinq
degrés en cinq à dix mille ans
c'est juste ça
nous avons donc un précédent historique
à quelques degrés de chauffe et absolue
évaluer
et vous voyez le genre de chose qu'il
produit en ce qui concerne le
paysage
donc une autre façon de le dire
est que la variabilité naturelle de la
système
n'est pas du tout à l'échelle de ce que nous
se déclenchent bien aujourd'hui
donc le bon parallèle n'est pas le
poisson rouge qui résistera à tout ce qu'il
c'est bien toi qui ne peux pas résister à un
variation de quelques degrés de votre
température interne tant que j'impose
assez longtemps
d'accord
c'est le bon parallèle
donc si je mets en perspective maintenant ce que
s'est passé au cours du dernier millénaire ce
s'est passé au cours du siècle dernier et ce
pourrait arriver dans le futur c'est ce que
On dirait
ici vous avez une reconstruction de la
la dendrochronologie comme je disais
plus tôt essentiellement la température de
le siècle passé, donc c'est essentiellement
fait avec des analyses
à partir de 1860, vous devez attendre non alors laissez-moi
commentaire que vous avez un
mesure directe de la température
montée de la planète
et donc question
pourquoi ne l'avons-nous pas fait avant 1860
pourquoi pas avant 1860
non non
bien plus simple que ça
et en particulier avec quoi tu
mesurer une température avec un thermomètre
de quand date l'invention du thermomètre
non
1492. sauf qu'en 1492 vous avez un
thermomètre et mesurez-vous le
température n'importe où sur le globe avec
un thermomètre non c'est un peu
compliqué donc il faut beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
thermomètres pour commencer à mesurer
température en tous points du globe
d'ailleurs quelle est la surface de la terre
principalement fait de
de l'eau
avez-vous beaucoup de villes et beaucoup de
champs à la surface de l'océan
pas beaucoup et avez-vous de grandes
populations et beaucoup de thermomètres sur
la surface de l'océan non
vous avez encore des thermomètres sur l'océan
superficie où
Pardon
sur les bateaux absolument
donc puisque vous avez des moteurs et de la vapeur
moteurs que vous avez en particulier
thermomètres à l'entrée d'eau pour
mesurer la température de l'eau car
ceci est utilisé pour ajuster les machines et
même alors, il est arrivé que nous prenions
quelques échantillons, etc.
sauf que ces échantillons ne sont fabriqués que
sur les routes commerciales parce que les bottes circulent
pour transporter des marchandises si elles vont commencer
faire du tourisme où les patrons crient après
eux et vous devez donc attendre jusqu'à ce que nous
avoir suffisamment de routes commerciales à la surface
d'une planète pour que l'on considère que
les températures mesurées dans l'océan sont
représentatif de la température de l'eau
et donc d'avoir assez
thermomètres à la surface du sol et suffisamment
thermomètres sur les bateaux qui se déplacent
considérer que nous avons quelque chose qui
ça commence à ressembler à un
échantillon représentatif, nous considérons que
avant 1860 ce n'est pas le cas donc
à partir de 1860, nous sommes en mesure d'offrir un
mesure instrumentale
de la moyenne planétaire oui
non
c'est représentatif de la température
de l'eau où tu passes ce n'est pas la
le sillage d'un bateau ce n'est pas la traînée du
bateau qui chauffera l'eau jusqu'au
point qu'il perturbe la mesure
définitivement pas
et donc vous avez en perspective ici je
répéter trois températures mesurées en
différentes manières et
à différents moments
donc leurs analyses sont instrumentales
directement avec les thermomètres et leurs
des modèles
donc leurs thermomètres normaux nous entrons dans
la modélisation et c'est la modélisation de ce qui va
arriver plus tard
et ce que vous voyez sans le soupçon de
disons sans discussion possible
sur ce graphique est que la venue
la variation de température est quelque chose qui
est sans point commun
quel que soit le scénario adopté
avec
la variabilité naturelle du système afin
même à deux degrés c'est la la
conséquence bien la la la conclusion
qu'il faut garder à l'esprit même à deux
degrés, nous verrons un considérable
quantité de dysfonctionnements dans le système
qui n'existait pas jusqu'à présent même à deux
degrés
d'accord
si on bien en fait voici la courbe
qui vous donne la variation de
système
sur des échelles de temps disons bien depuis le
se trouve le dernier maximum de la période glaciaire donc ici
vous avez la reconstruction de la
température du passé avec des analyses si
quand on est à l'échelle des dizaines de
des milliers d'années ce n'est plus le
cernes d'arbres que nous utilisons c'est un
reconstruction avec les isotopes de
l'oxygène et l'hydrogène dans les calottes glaciaires
c'est ce dont j'ai parlé en dernier
temps
alors
vous voyez ici que la température au
le début de l'holocène était légèrement
plus grand que
qu'y avait-il derrière
c'est ce que nous avons déjà fait aujourd'hui
et qu'avec la bonne échelle c'est quoi
nous pourrions faire dans le siècle à venir
donc vous voyez qu'évidemment l'image de
le mur est assez bon une montée de quelques
degrés en un siècle
ressemble plus à un mur qu'à une promenade
le parc que ça va vraiment causer
les principaux centres commerciaux fonctionnent tout autour du
système
et nous reviendrons plus en détail
ensuite
quelque chose qu'il est important de conserver
dérange
c'est que cette température monte déjà
en cours
et qui va accélérer
de temps en temps ça va oui
oui
pour être exact, le rayonnement solaire est
conducteur 230 watts par mètre carré et
l'effet de serre ressemble plus à 170
mais c'est cet ordre de grandeur oui
le supplément est de 2,5 watts par carré
mètres
oui madame ça suffit
eh bien d'abord c'est 2,5 aujourd'hui et je signale
qu'il augmente avec le temps
et par exemple nous verrons un peu
plus tard que ce que nous appelons rpc
voies de concentration représentatives
en fait le nombre que vous avez après
il représente le forçage radiatif dans
2100 donc le rcp 4.5 fait 4.5 watts par
mètres carrés en 2100 donc ils augmentent
dans les simulations évidemment au fil du temps et
il faut d'ailleurs voir que pour
d'ampleur
et c'est vraiment un ordre de grandeur
un pour cent d'augmentation de la serre
l'effet est d'un degré de plus
fondamentalement
donc quatre pour cent d'augmentation, c'est environ quatre
degrés fondamentalement et je dis fondamentalement
parce que le processus n'est pas du tout linéaire
et ce sont les ordres de grandeur
donc je disais le terrain qui monte
Température
donc de temps en temps ça prend un peu
Pause
cette petite pause n'appelle pas
se demander ce qui se passe
alors
tout simplement parce qu'il y a un peu
illusion d'optique dans cette histoire
beaucoup de gens pensent que ce qui est
représentatif de ce qui se passe à
le moment est la température croissante de
l'atmosphère donc en fait la montée de
températures atmosphériques à la pointe du
iceberg
parce que ce que ce diagramme vous montre
c'est là que les suppléments d'énergie qui
provient de ces suppléments dans
l'effet de serre va
et cette énergie supplémentaire que vous voyez dans
cette image
est que plus de 90% ne chauffent pas
l'atmosphère mais l'océan
c'est l'océan et je t'ai dit ça
avant de
qui contrôle l'inertie du système
sur l'échelle de temps qui nous intéresse
ici cependant il suffit que le
changer
qui répartit l'énergie entre les
océan et l'atmosphère change un
peu dans une année donnée par exemple vous
avoir un
la circulation qui enfouit la chaleur dans
l'océan il suffit que ce soit un
peu plus actif ou sur le pays un
un peu plus faible et en ce moment vous
aura soit une accélération d'un
élévation de la température superficielle
ou au contraire ralentissement de la hausse
ou même un léger refroidissement de la surface
température au cours d'une année donnée
variabilité de l'atmosphère
la température dépend notamment de
ce processus d'enterrement à la chaleur
dans l'océan
qui peut subir de petites variations
en raison de petites variations dans l'océan
circulation, cela n'exclut pas le fait
que dans l'ensemble
le système accumule de plus en plus
énergie
mais si cette énergie est un intermédiaire
couche de l'océan par exemple vous n'avez pas
voir la traduction en surface
température oui
comment se passe l'échange d'énergie
place
ah
ben on verra ça plus tard ça dépend
la circulation océanique à grande échelle
vous avez un processus convectif dans le
océan et quand l'eau qui était sur le
la surface va en profondeur, elle emporte avec elle
chauffe bien
et il est remplacé en surface par
de l'eau un peu plus froide provenant
les profondeurs et il suffit que cela
mouvement accélère ou ralentit un
peu et ont essentiellement un processus de
enfouissant la chaleur de la surface vers le
poussière qui accélère ou sur le pays
ralentit un peu et c'est donc un
élément qui dirige la surface
Température
alors
nous allons maintenant commencer à regarder euh
les impacts euh un peu plus en détail
il y a deux choses à retenir
donc un je répète l'ampleur de la
l'impact dépend de l'ampleur de la
émissions
donc tout ce que je vais vous dire de
maintenant c'est qualitatif
semi-quantifié pour un certain nombre de
Conséquences il y a des gens qui ont couru
modèles indiquant si les émissions sont
plus un tel impact que nous sommes en mesure de mettre
dans une telle fourchette alors que si le
les émissions sont plus faibles un tel impact que nous
préférerais le mettre dans une telle gamme mais
ça va dépendre en gros
et surtout le point essentiel est le
dernière phrase mais c'est pour dire que ce que je
vous montrer à partir de maintenant est illustratif
ce sont des choses dont nous avons déjà
avoir des indications
il y a beaucoup de choses que nous allons faire
apprenons au fur et à mesure c'est-à-dire que nous
réalisera
une fois qu'il est trop tard
qu'il y a ce truc qui bleu qui
nous n'avions pas vu venir et c'est
commencer à prendre de l'élan
et qu'il y aura de plus en plus
et nous devrons vivre avec là-bas
y aura-t-il de plus en plus
parce que le système est beaucoup trop complexe
trop chaotique et trop fortement non linéaire
pour que nous puissions identifier les risques en
risque
géographie par géographie et date par date
Qu'est-ce qui pourrait arriver
d'accord et cela restera pour toujours
impossible
donc une blague que je fais souvent c'est tu vois
il y a une expérience que nous avons fait trois
milliards de fois ou quatre milliards de fois ou
cinq millions de fois avec des humains et c'est
appelé se marier et avec tout ça
j'ai gardé qui se marie aujourd'hui tu ne le fais pas
J'ai une idée d'où ça sera dans 30
années alors imaginez une expérience que nous
font pour la première fois qui est aussi
complexe comme celui-ci il est complètement
délirant de prétendre dire à l'avance
toutes les conséquences que cela aura
dans quelques décennies
d'accord pour que nous puissions avoir une idée juste
comme avec le couple que je ne connais pas dans 30
ans s'il sera toujours marié ou non
mais ils auront toujours deux bras et
deux jambes bien à moins qu'ils n'aient un
accident mais ils n'en auront pas quatre pour
Exemple
ils ne feront pas trois mètres de haut donc là
sont un certain nombre de choses que nous sommes
toujours capable de dire et il y en a quelques-uns
des choses dont nous sommes absolument incapables
disant que je ne sais pas s'ils auront
deux trois zéro ou cinq enfants ou
si nous sommes toujours ensemble ou où
ils vivront
donc pour le climat c'est exactement pareil
chose ou plus exactement c'est pire depuis
encore une fois c'est une expérience que nous
font pour la première fois en
expériences que nous menons pour
première fois c'est très très rare que ça
donne exactement des résultats que l'on peut
prévoir à l'avance partout et tout
le temps
une fois j'ai dit ça
il y a un certain nombre de constantes dans ce
histoire
la première
est-ce
le vermifuge aura une structure spatiale
qui est déjà plus ou moins connu
le premier euh
que tu vois
c'est que la température donc ici pour
exemple vous l'avez en juin juillet et
août
et ici en décembre janvier et
février
tu vois que quelque soit la saison
la hausse de température est plus
prononcé sur la surface terrestre qu'il
est sur les océans parce que les océans ont
plus d'inertie thermique
la deuxième chose que vous voyez est que le
l'élévation de température est proportionnellement plus
prononcé en hiver
dans les hautes latitudes septentrionales que dans
l'été dans les hautes latitudes septentrionales
en d'autres termes, l'augmentation de la température
aller plus vite en hiver qu'en été
c'est ce que je t'ai dit la dernière fois
ce que vous voyez aussi, c'est que dans tous les cas
il y a un endroit et je reviendrai
à cela plus tard je vous expliquerai pourquoi
où l'élévation de température est moindre
prononcé qu'ailleurs dans le
l'hémisphère nord est l'immédiat
au sud du groenland bien vous remarquez
qu'il est présent que ce soit dans
été ou hiver
donc la première des conséquences que
vous verrez ici c'est que si
il y a un endroit où ça va
particulièrement chauffer c'est dans l'arctique
région et pour ceux d'entre vous qui suivent
les nouvelles un peu que vous avez peut-être déjà
remarqué que c'est dans la région arctique
que de temps en temps il y a totalement
des températures époustouflantes et le mot
n'est pas trop fort en hiver
je crois que c'était le 1er janvier 2018 si
je me souviens bien que le
la température du pôle nord était
positif
je répète positif au-dessus de zéro
d'accord
alors
la deuxième chose
c'est ça euh
comme je vous l'ai dit plus tôt la température
monter
dépendra du scénario d'émission
alors te voilà euh
tant pis vous voyez apparaître l'acronyme rcp
donc je le répète représentant
voie de concentration
donc le 2.6 est un scénario où le
le forçage radiatif est en 2100 est de 2,6
watts par mètre carré qui est
à peu près ce que nous avons déjà aujourd'hui
en gros le 4.5 c'est qu'on a 4.5
et le 6 c'est qu'on a 6 watts i
supprimé volontairement pour vous ici
le plus élevé des 4 scénarios rc rcp
utilisé aujourd'hui qui s'appelle le 8.5 donc je
je te l'ai pris c'est un
manipulation que je suppose que je l'ai retiré
parce que ce scénario avec un rcp très élevé
correspond à des émissions très élevées mais
c'est-à-dire une situation qui pour moi est
totalement virtuel dans lequel l'humanité serait
être de mieux en mieux et il y aura
il y aurait de plus en plus d'hommes avec un
de plus en plus
économie importante alors même que le changement climatique
est à son maximum de conséquences possibles
et donc vous devez avoir la planète qui
est mort de faim donc c'est un peu
compliqué pour moi de mettre les deux
ensemble donc j'ai considéré que celui-ci je
en parlerait peu et de temps en temps
de temps en temps vous le verrez de toute façon mais je
en parlerai très peu car
il a une incohérence interne qui
est sans rapport avec les physiciens j'insiste
qui est lié au fait que le
scénarios élaborés par les
économistes qui n'ont pas le physique
limites à l'esprit par construction c'est
ce que je t'ai expliqué en premier
bien sûr tant que l'économie ne
dépendent de facteurs limitants qui viennent
de la physique, il n'y a aucune raison pour que nous
ne peut pas avoir une économie extrêmement
important
avec
la physique très limitée et ce n'est pas un
problème pour eux mais c'est un problème pour
moi oui
non non pas du tout ce n'est que l'interne
dynamique du modèle um
c'est euh c'est le fait que tu as
entre les modèles encore des hypothèses je suis
vais vous donner un exemple qui est
très bien connu le paramétrage de
des nuages
donc je vous ai dit plus tôt que dans le
modèle standard nous avons une taille de grille de 50
à 100 kilomètres pour vous tous qui
J'ai un jour rêvé en été couché dans
l'herbe observant les nuages ​​tu vas
ont remarqué que les nuages ​​ne
parcourir 100 kilomètres tout de suite
il n'y a pas beaucoup de nuages ​​qui vont d'ici à
cabane
et que vous pouviez voir tout à la fois par
le chemin
ou ça s'appelle une couverture extensible et
c'est déprimant et c'est l'hiver
et donc
le nuage est un phénomène sous le maillage
donc tenir compte de la couverture nuageuse
dans les modèles que vous êtes obligé de
paramétrer cette couverture
en d'autres termes ce que votre modèle sera
simuler est la circulation de l'eau
vapeur dans l'atmosphère et en fonction de
la vapeur d'eau que vous avez dans votre
engrener
je veux dire dans ta boite à chaussures bien tu le feras
paramétrer et ce n'est pas une dynamique
c'est une chose paramétrée
quantité de nuages ​​que vous avez dans ce
engrener
d'accord
bien
selon les techniques qui sont
utilisé par les différents modélisateurs pour faire
ce paramétrage
la quantité de nuages ​​que vous avez
pour une même concentration de vapeur d'eau et
le fait que ces nuages ​​soient bas
nuages ​​d'altitude ou de haute altitude
qui n'ont pas le même impact sur
climat bien cela variera de
d'un modèle à l'autre et cela
le paramétrage à lui seul explique la plupart des
la dispersion des résultats entre les modèles
d'accord l'essentiel de la dispersion de
résultats entre les modèles est la façon dont les modèles
approcher la représentation des nuages
alors voici un exemple qui est le plus
exemple emblématique et il a absolument
rien à voir avec le retour climatique
sur l'économie puisque je vous ai dit qu'il
n'est pas pris en compte par
construction dans n'importe quelle simulation
donc ce que je disais c'est que selon
sur l'intensification de l'um
effet de serre disons que vous avez
des réchauffements plus ou moins
prononcé mais vous trouvez ces constantes
à chaque fois c'est-à-dire que ça chauffe
proportionnellement plus que les continents
au-delà des océans plus au nord
que l'hémisphère sud et que
vous avez toujours cette singularité juste
au sud du groenland oui
c'est l'augmentation du rayonnement
le forçant c'est l'augmentation de l'effet de serre
concentration de gaz dans l'atmosphère et
d'où le forçage radiatif
c'est donc le nom d'un scénario et
la valeur que vous avez après rcp vous donne un
forçage radiatif en 2100
ceci étant le cas pour une même valeur de
rcp et 2100 vous pouvez avoir plusieurs
trajectoires donc c'est une trajectoire et
j'aurais pu te les montrer mais ça
est une trajectoire avec laquelle je préfère rester
mon scénario d'émission parce qu'il
à peu près se chevauche et l'émission
le scénario est quelque chose qui est beaucoup
plus facile à visualiser car c'est le
quantité que nous émettons
variabilité c'est-à-dire des modèles
ah le forçage n'est pas variable ici le
2.6 est une trajectoire de forçage définie
par contre avoir 20 modèles donne
vous une dispersion d'un résultat parce que vous
avoir un résultat par modèle mais ce sont
tous les mêmes scénarios rcp
ensuite les mêmes modèles que vous pouvez utiliser
eux avec un rcp 2.6 et rcp 4.5 etc et
à ce stade, évidemment, ils ne donnent pas
vous les mêmes résultats
non non non non c'est comparé au
ère pré-industrielle c'est-à-dire euh ça
est de 2,5 dû aux hommes
et en effet la référence préindustrielle
à cause de l'homme c'est zéro oui
alors là si quelqu'un peut me donner un
prévision fiable de l'endroit où les migrants
sera dans ce genre d'évolution je paye
lui aime les cerises et je n'en prends pas
des risques parce que ça commence à être le
saison
cela fait généralement partie de la fin de
des conséquences en chaîne qui sont
des choses imprévisibles ce que vous pouvez gérer
prédire sont les facteurs de pression qui
vont provoquer ce genre de choses
mais après cela, personnellement, je ne peux pas dire
vous si les gens vont d'abord migrer ou
mourir d'abord à cause d'une épidémie donc si
y'a nos épidémies on va pas s'en vouloir
parce qu'ils seront morts donc je ne le fais pas
connaître la réponse à cette question, je vais
y venir à la fin d'une présentation
sur les conséquences parce que c'est la première
chose qui vient à l'esprit d'un
journaliste mais c'est la dernière chose
qui vient à l'esprit d'un scientifique
quand cela lui vient à l'esprit parce que
précisément il est très difficile d'être
prédictif sur ce genre de choses
il faut comprendre que plus loin
on s'éloigne de la physique et plus
nous entrons dans des choses qui nous affectent
parce qu'encore une fois nous ne vivons pas dans un
monde de températures nous vivons dans un monde
des hommes s'il y a des choses à manger
ou non, qu'il s'agisse d'animaux ou non
et si nos voisins viennent chez nous
maison ou pas c'est le monde dans lequel
nous vivons et donc le physicien qu'il aime
le monde des paramètres physiques et il
veut rester dans ce monde et ne pas
s'aventurer trop autour d'elle pour les choses
qui sont
bien chaque fois que nous nous aventurons dans
des conséquences plus proches de nous
qui disent que nous avons ajouté une couche de complexité à
un raisonnement et donc une couche de
incertitude donc cela ne signifie pas que le
le risque n'est pas tout simplement signifie que c'est
difficile de le formaliser
je reviendrai dessus plus tard
alors
euh je vous ai dit que depuis 1860 nous avons
données d'observation sur la température
variations voici une traduction de cela
et c'est ce cas c'est depuis 1880 mais
peu importe
ce que vous voyez, c'est que puisque fondamentalement le
30 années glorieuses d'après-guerre il y a eu
une montée très caractéristique de la
températures et même avant
au cours de cette période
lorsque les températures ont temporairement
redescendu
une des hypothèses qui tient et
je dis l'une des hypothèses que
tient le coup, c'est que cette phase qui
correspond au début de ces
soi-disant indices 30 ans et donc
au début de l'accélération
l'industrialisation de l'humanité a disparu
main dans la main avec une grosse grosse émission de
dioxyde de soufre dans l'atmosphère
parce que nous utilisions beaucoup plus d'huile et
plus de pétrole et de charbon
qui sont des carburants soufrés et donc
il n'y avait pas d'anti-pollution
des mesures comme celles que nous avons aujourd'hui et nous
n'a pas purifié le dioxyde de soufre des fumées
donc on met beaucoup de sulfates dans le
l'atmosphère et ainsi il a refroidi le climat
un peu à cause de ça
c'est euh
l'explication que euh ben l'un des
des explications qui tiennent la route
parce que vous remarquez que si vous commencez
d'ici et que tu vas à
et qu'il y a la même tendance avec un
pic là qui continue après
et puis il y a une exploration
ce que vous voyez aussi, c'est qu'ici la tendance
est très très clair
cela n'empêche pas un certain nombre de
les gens encore aujourd'hui pour prendre un plus court
série chronologique qui leur convient et dites regardez
la température baisse il s'est arrêté
augmente car la température baisse
d'accord
bien évidemment il faut prendre le temps
des séries chronologiques
il faut donc appliquer le bon filtre
et vous ne devriez pas regarder peu de temps
série donc tu me diras qu'il y en a moins
les septiques climatiques inférieures et bien c'est
pas tout à fait certain ça dépend beaucoup
sur le pays où vous êtes
et il s'avère qu'il y en a un
pays qui n'est euh bien plus le
premier mais le deuxième émetteur de
gaz à effet de serre dans le monde
qui a une très faible influence sur
reste des pays occidentaux parce qu'il
détient actuellement sa monnaie de réserve
de choix qui s'appelle le dollar et
ce pays a la plus forte proportion
des septiques climatiques dans le monde d'après
l'arabie saoudite et je ne me souviens plus lequel
est le deuxième donc là
alors
oui
c'est environ 20 pour cent
et les gens que tu connais qui sont tout à fait
fortement sceptique disons non euh
et avec la même mesure en france c'est
six pour cent
d'accord donc
oh non pas 20 c'est 15 désolé mais avec le
même mesure en france c'est six donc c'est
environ deux fois plus que les amis
alors
et euh
il est très différencié selon
la région géographique et donc
donc cette petite animation est encore une fois
là pour vous rappeler que c'est très facile
manipuler les statistiques
leur faire dire ce qu'ils ne disent pas
et ici vous avez un euh particulièrement euh
particulièrement classique
exemple disons
de ce genre de manipulation
il n'y a pas que la température globale
que nous pouvons analyser avec la température
lectures donc ici vous avez une évolution
de la température hémisphérique et vous
voir par exemple que la température
variations de l'hémisphère sud
sont globalement un peu moins impactés
et un peu plus lent maintenant
que les variations du nord
hémisphère c'est la conséquence de
ce que je vous ai dit plus tôt plus de continents
dans l'hémisphère nord et une vitesse plus rapide
évolution dans l'arctique
ici aussi tu as différencié
moyennes entre continents et océans
donc on retrouve la conclusion que j'ai dit
vous plus tôt au-dessus des continents que vous voyez
ici cette diminution probablement due à la
industrialisation croissante
et là tu vois que maintenant ça évolue
plus lentement
qu'au dessus des continents ce qui est assez
Ordinaire
avec les différences d'inertie terminale
ici vous avez une courbe les amis
alors tu vois ça
la france a aujourd'hui des anomalies de température
par rapport à la moyenne 1961 1990 qui sont
maintenant tout positif et qui dans la tendance vous
connaissent la tendance augmentent
pour que par exemple tout au long de votre vie
vous verrez dans le journal tant que
nous avons des journaux à intervalles réguliers
nous venons de casser la température
record oui eh bien tu sais qu'on va casser
encore et encore et encore et encore
et encore tant qu'il y a du monde pour
mesurer la température et les journaux pour
imprimer des trucs sur la température
rompre périodiquement avec la température
enregistre oui
Pardon
eh bien on s'en fiche on en prend
référence je veux dire
pour caractériser une variation vous vous mettez
le zéro de l'ordonnance où que vous soyez
vouloir
et ici dans ce cas la moyenne n'est pas
plus de 100 mais plus de 30 ans
donc par contre ce qui est certain c'est
qu'en ce qui concerne le climat, nous
ont tendance à considérer
la
la série temporelle minimale pour regarder quoi
se passe quelque part il y a 30 ans
d'accord
habituellement ouais
ici vous avez une variation de l'hiver et
températures estivales en france
là aussi depuis un siècle
et donc ce que vous voyez
et c'est une chose intéressante à garder
à l'esprit notamment pour le dimensionnement
grille électrique
qui est que le
variation de température par rapport à
l'hiver
qui est la même qu'en ce qui concerne
l'été c'est-à-dire qu'il augmente
dans tous les cas ben ça n'éclipse pas
la variabilité annuelle qui tend à être
plus important qu'en ce qui concerne
été donc ici vous avez un point qui est
extrêmement singulier tu vois sinon le
les anomalies de température sont encore très
similaires d'une année sur l'autre alors que
leurs anomalies de température d'un
d'une année à l'autre, ils peuvent varier beaucoup plus
et donc ce que ce graphique vous dit dans
particulier est que le réchauffement climatique en tant que
ensemble
ne sera pas ou n'empêchera pas d'être plus
précise aujourd'hui l'occurrence de temps
à l'époque des hivers qui sont qui peuvent
être plus frais que la moyenne
d'accord ça n'empêche pas ça
ce sera évidemment moins et
moins fréquent mais ça ne l'empêchera pas
tu as maintenant oui
la normale saisonnière est toujours la même
comme la moyenne sur 30 ans de vous savez
61.90 mais encore une fois c'est juste une question
de déplacer l'origine
un euh
l'un des moyens
pour savoir si ce qui s'est déjà passé
car le réchauffement de la surface d'une planète est
en effet grâce à une serre supplémentaire
effet c'est bien sûr pour voir si le
modèle vous donne une élévation de température sur
le terrain qui est compatible avec le
effet de serre supplémentaire qui a
été mis dans l'atmosphère mais un autre
le moyen d'avoir cette confirmation est de voir
si la structure spatiale
de l'élévation de température correspond à
ce que nous sommes en droit d'attendre d'un
climat qui se réchauffe avec un supplément
Effet de serre
et je pense que je l'ai déjà dit une fois mais si
pas je vais répéter
dans un climat qui se réchauffe par
effet de serre supplémentaire l'un des
choses auxquelles on devrait s'attendre est de trouver
une élévation de température plus prononcée sur
les continents et particulièrement
prononcé dans la zone arctique
et ici vous avez une reconstruction de
la variation de température sur le 20
siècle
et ce que tu vois
c'est que c'est ce qu'on a observé aujourd'hui
dans l'élévation de température
qui est déjà observable et donc vous
voyez qu'il est particulièrement prononcé
dans la zone arctique et qu'il est plus
particulièrement prononcée dans le
continents que sur l'océan où il
s'est réchauffé et vous voyez aussi et encore
j'y reviendrai plus tard que nous
ont en effet
cette singularité ici juste au sud de
Groenland
une des conséquences du réchauffement
températures, c'est qu'évidemment nous allons
avoir une augmentation du maximum
températures
tant que les températures obéissent
une distribution
si vous ne changez pas la forme d'un
distribution et que vous déplacez le
moyenne, vous aurez évidemment
eh bien vous verrez apparaître des événements
qui dépasse la température maximale
que vous aviez avant voir si le maximum
la température était là et que tu bouges
la moyenne les températures maximales
atteint sera là
maintenant tant que vous ne changez pas le
forme d'un puits gaussien
probablement la densité de probabilité
dire des événements qui dépassent l'ancien
températures maximales
ne sont pas extrêmement importants
d'autre part si en même temps
vous augmentez la variabilité
alors
vous verrez une augmentation beaucoup plus importante de
événements
qui dépassera l'ancien maximum
mais il s'avère que malheureusement
on s'attend dans un climat qui se réchauffe
que la variabilité augmente également tous
c'est bien une des conséquences
ce qui est attendu avec cela signifie que
événements extrêmement chauds
ou ou extrêmement sec
aura tendance à augmenter
plus rapide disons que la moyenne
il y a un autre élément de variabilité
qui peut entrer en jeu
et ici je vais vous donner l'exemple de
L'Europe 
l'europe comme vous le savez est soumise à une
régime de vent d'ouest
il s'avère que sur l'atlantique
Tu as deux
désolé quatre régimes
de positionnement respectif des
la dépression et l'anticyclone qui peuvent
se produire
tu as un régime celui-ci
appelé le nao moins dans lequel vous avez
la
anticyclone à haute pression dans le nord
et la dépression de basse pression dans le
sud
vous avez ici un régime dans lequel il est
l'exact opposé que vous avez ici un
régime dans lequel il s'agit d'un régime est-ouest
structurant et ici un régime dans lequel
c'est une structuration est-ouest inverse
ici vous avez la fréquence
de survenance de ces situations dans
année tout va bien
alors ouais année après année alors qu'est-ce que c'est
les graphiques vous disent, c'est qu'avec une forte
variabilité annuelle je veux dire allez bien
essentiellement sur quelques décennies, vous avez
environ 25
probabilité
de se retrouver dans l'un de ces quatre
situations en d'autres termes si vous regardez
sur quelques décennies et vous ignorez
variabilité annuelle
cela se produit 25% du temps vis-à-vis
25 contre 25 contre 25.
et quand vous êtes dans chacun de ces quatre
situations que vous voyez ici que le
température et précipitations
présentent des anomalies par rapport à la moyenne
qui ne sont pas les mêmes
alors quand tu es en rouge
alors vous avez un surplus et en bleu alors
vous avez un déficit alors faites attention aux
les températures et les précipitations ce n'est pas
interprété de la même manière évidemment
et vous voyez que le surplus et le
déficit ne se situent pas du tout dans
même endroit selon la situation
que vous avez dans l'atlantique alors ici
lors de l'inversion de l'atlantique nord
oscillation bien vous voyez que le
les excédents et les déficits sont à peu près
inversé dans le nord de l'europe
euh
là c'est pareil en inversant ces
deux situations bien vous voyez que sur le
partie nord de l'europe vous avez
extrêmement construit contrasté
situations concernant les précipitations
une des questions que les modélisateurs ne se posent pas
sait répondre encore aujourd'hui c'est fait
la fréquence d'apparition de chacun des
ces quatre situations changent dans un
réchauffement climatique
si la réponse est oui, cela signifie que nous
avoir un processus d'amplification en europe
par rapport à l'évolution globale
soit dans un sens soit dans l'autre
si la situation d'amplification
va dans le sens du moins
précipitations et plus de température nous
sont bien pires que s'il va le
autrement
et j'insiste bien pire
parce que vous avez un impact direct sur ce
est mangé et un impact direct sur ce que
grandit
et c'est très difficile aujourd'hui de savoir euh
rien à ce sujet
avec des modèles
alors
application ici vous avez le
um la distribution de température dans
Suisse donc ne me demande pas pourquoi
la suisse c'est probablement parce que c'était
une équipe de suisse
chercheurs qui l'ont fait
alors
dans la situation pré-industrielle euh non
désolé je dis des bêtises
voici donc la moyenne de fin de
20ième siècle
et ici le climat futur à la fin
21e siècle
ce que vous voyez, c'est que non seulement le
moyenne d'une distribution de température
modifié
mais vous voyez aussi que la variabilité
a considérablement augmenté
et donc
les températures extrêmement élevées ne sont pas
vont être un peu plus fréquents, ils
seront considérablement plus fréquents
tu es peut-être un peu jeune pour
souvenez-vous de la canicule de 2003
car c'était quand même il y a 16 ans
il y a 16 ans
savoir qui se souvient de la canicule
de 2003
d'accord pas mal
bien la canicule de 2003
ce que je vais vous dire, c'est que dans un
climat qui se réchauffe de quelques degrés
quelques degrés donc c'est ce que nous sommes fixés
pour bien réussir qui devient le
été normal donc l'été normal est
l'été normal dans la statistique
sens c'est-à-dire que c'est le
été qui sépare 50 pour cent de la
les étés les plus frais de 50 des plus chauds
étés
cela signifie donc qu'à la fin de
le siècle avec un réchauffement de quelques
degrés
de
les étés seront plus chauds que l'été 2003.
donc si dans les conséquences que
vous pouvez facilement imaginer que vous pouvez dire
adieu les forêts
nous pouvons dire au revoir à une partie de la
récolter etc c'est assez facile à
comprendre que tout ça euh disparaît
là donc c'est pour préciser qu'un
variation de quelques degrés d'un
moyenne planétaire
ce n'est pas du tout représentatif de
limite supérieure de la température
supplément qui absorbera le plus
événements chauds graves ce n'est pas du tout
représentant de celui
autres conséquences
du réchauffement climatique
au niveau du sol qui sont attendus je
vous en a parlé la dernière fois en parlant
sur le processus physique au travail
disons simplement du fait que par
intercepter la température plus près de
le terrain nous allions avoir moins
qui serait intercepté dans la partie supérieure
bonne ambiance il faut s'attendre a avoir un
refroidissement d'une stratosphère ce que vous voyez
sur ce graphique est que puisque nous savons comment
pour mesurer la température dans
stratosphère c'est-à-dire depuis la
départ des ballons sondes
Eh bien, nous pouvons mesurer la température dans
la stratosphère et ce que nous observons est
que ça descend
ça descend d'une manière qui a du sens
avec l'effet de serre supplémentaire
la deuxième conséquence qu'il y aura
être avec le réchauffement climatique ou plus exactement
avec le changement climatique
c'est une variation des précipitations donc
ce que je t'ai dit la dernière fois quand je
simulé le fonctionnement global d'un
système pour vous avec la petite animation
je t'ai montré
est-ce que dans un climat plus chaud vous
ont généralement plus d'évaporation et
donc plus de précipitations
par contre cet evap
non désolé cette précipitation
n'a aucune raison
à répartir uniformément sur la surface d'un
planète
ni spatialement
ni temporairement
et donc la grande question est ce qui est
à l'évolution de ces
précipitations
il y a une difficulté de modélisation qui est
lié à ce que j'ai mentionné plus tôt à propos de
nuages ​​qui est que depuis
les précipitations sont liées au nuage
couverture
bien
si vous rencontrez des difficultés pour paramétrer
couverture nuageuse
on a une incertitude plus grande
que sur la hausse de température sur le
variation des précipitations
néanmoins nous aurons encore quelques
conclusions solides donc ce que vous voyez est
que globalement les précipitations sont
aura tendance à augmenter
brusquement dans les hautes latitudes septentrionales
donc ça ne t'intéresse qu'à moitié car
il n'y a pas beaucoup de monde qui y habite
toutefois
ce que vous voyez, c'est qu'il y a des régions
où les précipitations auront tendance à
diminuer
donc si vous regardez cette carte
un peu
macroscopiquement
ce que vous voyez, c'est que les précipitations
augmenter aux hautes latitudes ainsi que
globalement dans la bande équatoriale et je fais
dire la bande équatoriale de l'autre
main ils auront tendance à diminuer
ils auront tendance à fortement diminuer
dans les bandes tropicales
que vous voyez ici
et ici
et la région du monde où
les précipitations diminueront le plus
pas de chance, c'est là où nous vivons
vous voyez que là où les précipitations
diminuera le plus parmi toutes les régions
du monde c'est autour du
bassin méditerranéen et le pourtour de la
bassin méditerranéen compte notamment un certain nombre
de pays ici qui sont
pas du tout suffisant au niveau de la nourriture
et qui ont aujourd'hui besoin d'importer de la nourriture pour
population en croissance rapide
et en fait je n'ai pas le temps aujourd'hui
mais j'ai fait une conférence à physique shimi
pari université euh
il y a quatre ans
dont le titre était de daech à cop21 en
que j'ai expliqué comment ce qui a été
appelé le printemps arabe a eu un effet extrêmement
important déterminant énergétique du climat
et en fait ce qui s'est passé là-bas
émeutes de la faim dans les pays importateurs qui
n'étaient pas en mesure de subventionner leurs importations
pour toujours la population et donc exactement la même
chose comme en 1789 s'est produite mais dire
droite et la syrie a un processus de déclenchement
ce qui n'est pas très très loin de ça
ce genre de choses va se répéter
lui-même bien voir comment les choses sont
lui-même simplement parce que les précipitations
continuera de s'affaiblir autour du
bassin méditerranéen et donc il
rendra encore plus difficile d'avoir
soi d'avoir l'autonomie alimentaire dans
ces pays et d'ailleurs je vais prendre
votre question plus tard et outre le
la sécheresse aura malheureusement tendance à augmenter
vers le sud de l'europe et vous
sait peut-être qu'aujourd'hui déjà l'Espagne a
une agriculture qui est en partie alimentée par
pompage d'aquifères qui ne
se reconstituer donc c'est un problème
qui préoccupera beaucoup les européens sur
leur propre sol aussi en peu de temps
so euh so so so quand le ipcc présente ça
c'est une tendance intermodale
autour de plus d'environ 20 modèles et donc cela
est malheureusement très robuste
conclusion c'est-à-dire que tous les
modèles convergent sur le fait que la jante
du bassin méditerranéen va s'assécher
vous avez des endroits colorés en blanc
où vous n'avez pas de convergence entre
modèles juste généralement là c'est
malheureusement très très convergent
alors
ensuite
vous n'avez pas que les précipitations
cela importe
tu as aussi une variation d'évaporation
parce que la teneur en eau du sol
qui conditionne si les plantes vont
grandir ou pas
est le résultat de ce qui tombe moins le
résultat de ce qui s'évapore ou se dérobe
rapidement
par exemple dans les zones de mousson où la pluie
est aussi quelque chose d'absolument
crucial pour que les gens survivent bien vous
peut avoir des précipitations qui s'intensifient
mais qui viennent après une saison sèche qui
était plus sec donc le sol est plus
imperméable et à ce moment l'eau
ruisselle sur le sol qui parce que
il est inondé d'ailleurs mais ne l'est pas
préservée par le sol donc qui n'est pas
bon disons pour la végétation l'idéal
pour la végétation pour ceux d'entre vous qui ont
été en irlande ou en bretagne c'est un
petite bruine démoralisante toute l'année
rond c'est absolument parfait
c'est quand il fait beau trois
fois par jour comme le dit le proverbe irlandais
c'est idéal
mais quand vous avez des épisodes qui sont très
concentré malheureusement ce n'est pas très
bonne colère donc ce que vous voyez ici est
évaporation
et soyez prudent car la remise des diplômes est
que plus c'est bleu plus c'est
augmente et vous voyez que dans un certain nombre
des régions du monde et dans
particulier sur la plupart des pays émergés
l'évaporation des terres va de quelque part
entre le même qu'aujourd'hui à plus
intense qu'aujourd'hui donc en tout cas même
s'il pleut plus tu vas avoir
une évaporation notamment sur terre
qui aura tendance à s'intensifier et donc ici
vous avez quelque chose qui est un composite
de ce que je viens de mentionner
donc les précipitations et l'évaporation qui
est l'évolution de l'humidité du sol
de sorte qu'en fait il contrôle directement le
rendement agricole essentiellement et si
les écosystèmes vont bien ou pas
ce que vous voyez ici, c'est que nous allons
pour trouver des choses que j'ai déjà
mentionné ainsi la périphérie de la
le bassin méditerranéen a tendance à s'assécher
là où vous avez des points est où le
les conclusions sont très robustes c'est la
euh d'accord je finis juste de commenter
et je répondrai à ta question juste après
alors c'est comme ça que tu comprends ça
graphique, vous voyez également cette partie de
l'australie là le quart sud-ouest
qui se dessèche un peu et le
coin sud-est aussi
et c'est là que vous avez pour ceux qui
suivent parfois des agriculteurs qui ne sont pas
très content de ce qui t'arrive
peut-être déjà entendu parler de l'eau
problèmes en afrique du sud
et tu vois que c'est cohérent avec
la carte ici et donc c'est le très mauvais
news si vous avez le bassin amazonien qui
sécher
c'est quelque chose qu'elle est
ne va absolument pas s'en sortir
d'une forêt parce que là vous avez le
le plus grand stock de debout couvert sur le
planète et vous voyez aussi l'intensification
sécheresse sur le sud des états-unis
Et sur le Mexique donc le Mexique est comme le nord
Afrique
intensification démographique croissante de
sécheresses et donc euh
indisponibilité de l'eau
donc c'est la même question de savoir comment
ça va finir est un
gros point d'interrogation
comme je le disais plus tôt
oh mon mauvais il y avait une question à la
retour
oui
oh non car la vapeur d'eau se condense
en fait ce que tu as dans l'atmosphère
est la pression de vapeur saturante et si vous
plus il pleut plus il ne s'évapore pas
augmenter la pression de vapeur saturante
ça circule plus vite en gros
ce qui conditionne la vapeur saturante
la pression est la température du
atmosphère donc plus la température est élevée
est d'autant plus grande sa capacité à transporter
ou la concentration de vapeur d'eau dans
l'ambiance est essentiellement
plus il est humide, plus sa
capacité à être humain
oui
oui cela influencerait négativement le
l'économie sauf qu'ils ne le prennent pas
en compte
oui que cela amortirait les émissions
ça les amortirait ça les abaisserait
mais ils n'en tiennent pas compte
c'est très compliqué car encore une fois vous
ici vous commencez à toucher à la
complexité de la chose parce que
là on est encore dans les paramètres physiques
après par exemple nous quand on commence
faire des simulations agronomiques avec
évolution de ces paramètres physiques
nous ajoutons un niveau de complexité pour que vous ayez
aller bien demander à tes amis agronomes
ils sont encore là pour le moment mais
ils iront bientôt au deuxième campus
comme tout le monde ben faut y aller
demandez-leur et ne riez pas, cela pourrait être
toi un jour non je plaisante
il faut donc aller leur demander comment ça marche
lorsque vous ajoutez la biologie d'une plante sur
haut de l'évolution de ces physiques
paramètres et la réponse est que c'est
compliqué comme vous le verrez un peu plus tard
mais vous ne mangez pas de paramètres physiques
tu manges des plantes
et les animaux qui mangeaient les plantes
alors
ce que ce graphique vous donne
est
l'évolution des pluies intenses
phénomènes
tels qu'ils ont été observés
donc cette fois dans le passé
et ce que vous voyez, c'est qu'il y a
déjà une augmentation des tendances donc
où c'est vert et bleu dans un certain nombre de
des endroits
donc l'excès de précipitations
peut se présenter sous la forme
malheureusement
d'un
augmentation des précipitations sur des
de courtes périodes de temps et c'est juste
perdu pour tout le monde parce que c'est de l'eau
que les sols ne tiennent pas
et en plus ça fait des dégâts
ce que vous voyez ici
et dans ce cas c'est aussi le passé
évolution de l'indice de sécheresse des sols
et vous voyez qu'il y a un certain nombre de
régions du monde où l'on trouve
tendances prévues pour l'avenir
donc là puisque c'est au milieu de
le sahara ce n'est pas très significatif mais
tu vois que sur l'afrique du sud on trouve
que sur le pourtour méditerranéen on trouve
ceci au sud-est et au sud-ouest de
Australie, nous trouvons cela sur cette partie de
brésil on trouve ça et au sud
États-Unis, nous constatons qu'il y a donc
déjà quelques régions du monde où
il semblerait
que nous avons déjà des sols qui sont
sécher
comme nous nous attendons à avoir dans le contexte de
un climat qui se réchauffe
en france tu as un intense
phénomènes de précipitation appelés sevenal
épisodes
As-tu entendu parler de cela
non
donc plusieurs épisodes se produisent à la fin de
L'été
quand la méditerranée est encore chaude
et
où
la température sur terre a commencé à
refroidir
et ils se produisent lorsque vous avez de l'air humide
du sud qui a traversé le
méditerranée si chargée d'eau que
monte en altitude donc avec condensation
de vapeur d'eau en rencontrant les sept
c'est-à-dire lors de la rencontre
contreforts du massif central
montagnes à ce moment il pleut des chats
et chiens le ministre de l'environnement
met ses bottes et va visiter le
ville qui a été inondée très lourdement
c'est un épisode de plusieurs et la fin a
maintenant devenu obligatoire donc une question
qui se pose évidemment
moment
que vous avez une surface chauffante
température vous aurez donc une
méditerranéen qui restera chaud plus longtemps
question n'augmentera-t-il pas
ce genre d'épisode
donc la réponse est que pour l'instant c'est
compliqué à dire
ce n'est pas tout à fait sûr que ce soit
le cas et vous avez ici une longue série
qui est réalisé par l'agence web française
sur le nombre de sept épisodes dans
la france avec deux seuils cumulatifs donc
tu vois je suis là
190 et 150 et vous voyez que
il n'est pas clair qu'il y ait pour le moment
est quelque chose
franchement en hausse par contre
ce qui est certain et donc c'est une seconde
chose à garder à l'esprit en ce qui concerne
les conséquences
est que la quantité de marchandises à inonder
augmente
car la france est encore dans le processus
d'urbanisation qui est la taille de
les villes continuent d'augmenter nous continuons
construire tous les quelques centaines de milliers
maisons donc ces logements nous mettons
quelque part nous ne les mettons pas sur le
étage supplémentaire de ceux qui déjà
existent donc nous occupons plus d'espace au sol
et il s'avère que dans le sud comme
autre part
presque toutes les villes ont été construites avec un
ruisseau qui les traverse
parce qu'historiquement c'était l'accès à
l'eau potable ou l'accès à l'eau qui
a été utilisé pour autre chose notamment pour
laver les vêtements dont vous avez entendu parler
machines à laver donc je n'ai pas
toujours été autour de l'eau courte était
nécessaire pour bien abreuver le bétail
fondamentalement, nous n'avions pas besoin d'eau et
donc toutes les villes de france ont été
construit sur un cours d'eau le plus grand
sur les rivières qui servaient de
voies de communication lorsque le flux
commence à croître rapidement parce qu'il y a
un épisode connu sûr si vous avez des choses
qui sont trop près du barrage du cours d'eau
c'est inondé
quand vous avez une pression foncière avec de nouveaux
habitants qui veulent construire
et que vous avez déjà intégré à tous
les endroits qui font du bien
mots que vous autorisez à intégrer
des endroits qui ne sont pas aussi bons et
surtout trop près du ruisseau
donc tu as
constructions supplémentaires
en nombre croissant qui mettent
eux-mêmes là où ils ne devraient pas parce
les élus ne sont pas en mesure de résister à la
pression des électeurs et à ce
moment où il y a une inondation il y a
plus de choses qui cassent le plus drôle
ce que j'ai vu est une caserne de pompiers
donc où habituellement les pompiers sont mobilisés
contre le déluge qui a été inondé
donc là
donc là on était dans les paramètres physiques
donc à ce stade je résume le
la température n'augmentera pas partout dans
de la même façon ça va augmenter je veux dire
il va y avoir plus d'énergie que
chauffe l'océan que l'énergie qui chauffe
l'atmosphère
et cela aura un impact sur les régimes de précipitations
nous allons maintenant nous concentrer sur une première
Conséquence sur les êtres vivants
car encore une fois c'est vraiment ça
nous intéresse
et ici vous avez
une carte qui représente le type de
écosystèmes que vous avez aujourd'hui sur le
surface d'une planète si on ne coupe pas
qu'ils fassent autre chose
et vous avez surtout
ici un schéma
qui vous donne le genre d'écosystème
que vous trouverez en fonction de
précipitations et température
et ce que vous observez et c'est pourquoi c'est
important d'avoir une bonne visibilité sur
précipitation
est que vous changez beaucoup plus rapidement le type
de l'écosystème si vous changez le
précipitations que si vous modifiez le
température c'est pourquoi en fait le
point essentiel dans le climat actuel
le changement n'est pas tant avec des variations dans
température comme la variation de
précipitations
qui en découlent évidemment mais c'est
principalement ce qui sera essentiel
donc la végétation va changer et
malheureusement ça ne changera pas
en général dans le bon sens sens
que nous aurons beaucoup plus
disparitions que créations car
le temps qu'il faut pour créer quelque chose est
beaucoup plus longtemps que le temps qu'il faut pour
disparaître
les simulations que je vais montrer
vous êtes maintenant nécessairement partiel
simulations
parce que les phénomènes les plus
dommageable pour l'homme et pour les plantes
ce n'est pas tellement des modifications bien plus
exactement cela peut être des modifications de
paramètres physiques, par exemple si
il n'y a plus d'eau les plantes vont mourir
mais vous pouvez également avoir des variations dans
compétition entre les espèces
qui génère d'énormes dégâts et dans
compétition entre les espèces vous
ont généralement ce qu'on appelle des parasites
insectes microbes virus champignons etc.
quand je parle de champignons, ce n'est pas
les champignons comestibles dont je parle
moisissure d'origine et d'autres belles choses comme
ce
bien
ces processus sont extrêmement difficiles
modeler
autrement dit
quelle est la fraction de chênes qui
meurent parce qu'ils seront victimes de
attaques d'oïdium au mauvais moment
dans un climat qui se réchauffe, il n'y a pas de
modèle unique aujourd'hui qui peut vous dire
ce genre de chose de manière fiable
alors
les précautions à prendre avec ce que je vais
vous montrer est que ceux-ci sont inférieurs
limites pas des limites supérieures c'est comment
le comprendre
ici vous avez une distribution de plage
arbres en france aujourd'hui donc
plus la densité est élevée et plus nous
aller vers le rouge et sinon c'est
bas donc fondamentalement vous avez le droit de
avoir des pêchers partout en france
mais globalement tu l'as plus facilement ici
que là-bas et plus facilement dans
pyrénées et là
et donc sur la droite vous avez un
distribution de hêtres que vous
pourrait avoir en 2100 dans un climat
modifié par la plus faible des émissions
scénarios que nous avons vus jusqu'à présent
ce que tu vois c'est qu'il y a un tout
un tas de régions en france où il n'y a pas
plus possible d'avoir des hêtres
surtout parce que c'est trop sec
même distribution pour le pin à fourrure
donc la fourrure aime les endroits où il fait frais
en hiver et tu vois qu'il fait frais
l'hiver est plus difficile dans un climat
qui est modifié pour que vous ayez des places
où tu peux avoir des fourrures qui rétrécissent
voici une autre conséquence de global
échauffement
ici vous avez l'inflammabilité de
forêts aujourd'hui avec trois indices
donc ici et là ça brûle très facilement
ici et là ça brûle encore
raisonnablement facilement et ailleurs pour le
moment il ne brûle pas
donc c'est aujourd'hui et c'est en 2040.
eh bien vous voyez qu'en 2040
l'inflammabilité de la fontainebleau
la forêt qui s'y trouve est celle de la
aujourd'hui
il y aura donc des incendies de forêt dans
fontainebleau malheureusement j'ai vraiment
comme la fontaine bleue de la forêt
ce que vous voyez, c'est que l'akitan va
brûler aussi facilement que le bord du
bassin méditerranéen aujourd'hui et ainsi de suite et
je ne suis pas content de te dire ça
je te dis ça parce que c'est
malheureusement que va-t-il se passer alors
rappelez-vous que
à 20 ans
euh
oh non je ne l'ai pas fait ou je ne pense pas l'avoir dit
vous que donc je vais parce que c'est
quelque chose qui est essentiel donc je vais
je reviens un peu pour te dire
que je reviendrai
ici
alors toi tu ne le vois pas bien là dessus
graphique, mais ce que vous voyez, c'est que tout
les simulations pour l'avenir dans
les 10 prochaines années même si on arrête
émissions et dans les 20 à 30 prochaines
ans quel que soit le scénario d'émission si
on les augmente la trajectoire est
exactement le même
donc fondamentalement ce qui se passera en 2040
est devenu totalement indépendant ou est
totalement indépendant de ce que notre
les émissions seront désormais
ce qui se passera après 2040 commencera
à différencier selon nos
émissions
et
mais tu vois ça avant
il n'y a pas de différence selon
scénario d'émissions, il y a donc un
conséquence absolument majeure qui est
que dans cette affaire
et c'est évidemment l'un des
difficultés d'un problème à portée de main dans un
manière en ce qui concerne l'atténuation de
changement climatique nous travaillons au mieux
pour nos enfants
d'accord, nous travaillons au mieux pour notre
enfants
concernant l'adaptation au changement climatique
ici, nous travaillons clairement pour
nous-mêmes
ainsi le fait par exemple que désormais
je vais aller mettre dans la fontaine bleue
forêt tous les mécanismes imaginables qui
l'empêchera de brûler c'est
quelque chose que nous faisons pour nous-mêmes
notre propre génération
demander aux français aux allemands
les chinois les indiens les américains et
les russes à émettre moins pour que
la forêt de fontainebleau brûle un peu moins
facilement c'est quelque chose que nous sommes
faire pour la génération suivante
c'est clair ouais
malheureusement à cause de l'inertie de
un système
donc on continue avec les conséquences
ici vous avez encore une fois un graphique
compliqué car toutes les cartes ipcc sont
compliqué ou
très riche en informations pour être plus
exact qui vous donne par type d'espèce
d'accord
donc donc ici par exemple vous avez des rongeurs
et ici vous avez des mammifères je pense
et ici vous avez des insectes et ainsi de suite
donc par type d'espèce
et ici vous avez
arbres qui vous donne le possible
l'aire de migration de l'espèce dans
kilomètres par décennie
en d'autres termes quand je réchaufferai le
climat je vais pousser les zones climatiques
vers les pôles d'accord en termes
de températures donc où j'ai eu le
températures que j'ai aujourd'hui à 45
degrés bien je les trouverai dans quelques
ans ou quelques décennies à 48 50 55
degrés de latitude
d'accord
donc je vais pousser les zones favorables
vers le pouls et donc si je veux mon
espèces pour survivre, ils doivent être capables de
migrer à une vitesse à laquelle les zones
bougent
à la vitesse à laquelle vous allez
déplacer les paramètres climatiques
et ce que ce graphique vous donnera
est les gammes rv ou ou les vitesses auxquelles
ces espèces
peut bouger
um en kilomètres par décennie
ce que représente la barre noire horizontale
est la moyenne
disons par catégorie d'espèces
c'est une sorte de moyenne
et ici
tu as des traits de couleur
qui vous donnent la vitesse de déplacement
associés aux différentes émissions
scénarios donc fondamentalement ici, il est dit que
dans le rcp 2.6 donc donc le plus bas
scénario d'émission sur les zones planes
ben en moyenne ça va bouger à ça
la rapidité
et ainsi de suite donc là vous avez les globals
pour ces scénarios
dans les zones planes ce que vous voyez est que
où il est plat, il se déplacera plus rapidement
que la moyenne simplement parce que là où vous
avez un terrain montagneux que vous n'avez pas
pour monter en latitude tu peux monter en
altitude de sorte que les espèces que vous avez dans
les alpes resteront dans les alpes sauf
qu'il sera plus haut en altitude tout
droit
d'autre part dans les avions
il sera poussé vers les pôles
ce que vous voyez c'est que par exemple quand
tu es en rcp 6.0
ben tu as une vitesse de déplacement
vers les pôles
qui grandement
dépasse la vitesse moyenne possible de
mouvement vers les poteaux des arbres
car un chêne met 40 ou 50 ans
être sexuellement mature
donc tu ne peux pas savoir
sauter partout comme une puce chaque année pour
avancez vers les pôles d'accord il faut attendre
passer par la prochaine génération avant
ça peut aller ailleurs
d'accord, alors ce que ce graphique vous dit
en gros c'est que dans rcp 6.0 ou même dans
rcp 4.5, vous perdrez essentiellement la plupart de
les forêts c'est ce qu'il vous dit
comme
en ce qui concerne les espèces herbacées
c'est pareil tu vas en perdre une partie
d'autre part certains mammifères et de
bien sûr si vous manquez de nourriture pour
mammifères ce truc devient partiellement
virtuel
et ainsi de suite et ainsi de suite et ainsi de suite
voir globalement c'est que pour la base de
les écosystèmes, c'est-à-dire les plantes, vous avez un
vitesse de migration possible de ces
écosystèmes vers les pôles qui est
beaucoup plus bas
pour la majorité des espèces
que la vitesse de déplacement des climats
paramètres qui seront observés afin
c'est ce que ce diagramme vous dit et
donc quand on dit que ce sera une perte de
écosystèmes, c'est justement à cause de ça
là vous avez un graphique qui parle de cela
pas sur les écosystèmes sauvages mais
écosystèmes gérés c'est-à-dire
l'agriculture donc l'agriculture est gérée
bonus écosystème spécifique c'est tout
ce qui signifie que vous avez une seule espèce donc
mono-spécifique celle qui pousse celle
nous intéresse on s'en fiche
d'autres alors maintenant c'est un peu moins vrai
parce que nous essayons de commencer à faire
les choses différemment et qu'est-ce que c'est
ce que ce graphique vous donne
est la tendance actuelle et je dis que le
tendance actuelle sur la variation par
décennie de rendements agricoles et ce
tu vois c'est que déjà aujourd'hui tu as
deux espèces qui sont les blés et les
maïs sur lequel nous avons déjà une baisse
tendance sur le rendement agricole et vous
voir les quatre principales céréales cultivées dans le
monde donc blé soja riz et maïs
avec une production annuelle d'environ 2
milliards de tonnes soit un peu plus de 2 milliards
tonnes
et donc vous voyez qu'en ce moment dans n'importe quel
cas il n'y en a pas un qui profite
à partir de cela
ici, il vous donne la perspective
résultats
alors
les résultats potentiels lorsque vous faites
simulations est ce que nous attendons avec un
barre d'erreur importante bien sûr
que les rendements agricoles
continuer à diminuer à l'avenir sous
l'effet du réchauffement climatique
et vous voyez que là où il pourrait diminuer
le plus rapide est dans les régions tempérées
si nous n'avons pas d'adaptation
mesures sauf que dans l'adaptation
mesures que vous avez par exemple l'irrigation
et l'irrigation n'est pas nécessairement
quelque chose de simple à mettre en place
parce que s'il s'arrête de pleuvoir
significativement bien s'il pleut moins
l'irrigation n'est pas forcément beaucoup
plus simple et c'est quelque chose qui est
absolument majeur sur une planète dont
la population, d'autre part, tend à
augmenter pour le moment parce que je
te rappeler encore une fois ce vieil adage
qui est à l'origine d'une révolution de
un estomac affamé n'a pas d'oreilles dans d'autres
des mots quand les gens n'ont rien à
manger ils deviennent fous et c'est normal et
c'est normal donc le fait que
les rendements agricoles diminuent et
pour répondre à la question de tout à l'heure
cela provoque-t-il des migrations ou
guerres ou je n'ai strictement aucune idée ou comme
émeutes ou révolutions
personne ne peut te dire à aucun moment entre maintenant
et plus tard donc là
ce sont généralement des choses qui vont
nous prendre par surprise et c'est absolument
évident donc certaines des surprises seront
viens de là oui
oui c'est interprétable y'a un gros
risque donc je répète quand il y a un gros
l'incertitude il y a un gros risque cela veut dire
que tu ne peux pas exclure que tu es mon
le curseur pointe et d'ailleurs le dernier
année en europe en 2018
vous avez eu une baisse de rendement de 20 à 30
dans certaines cultures
donc dans les pommes de terre une partie des céréales etc
en russie en 2010 vous avez eu une baisse de 45
% de la production céréalière
et c'est le début du 21
siècle
alors
il peut y avoir des augmentations sauf que si
vous comparez la russie et la pologne c'est
pas les mêmes zones cultivées ce n'est pas
les mêmes tonnages d'accord et en plus
ne dessert pas les mêmes marchés qu'il
pas forcément les mêmes grains etc et
donc non de ma mémoire en patate l'année dernière
tout le monde a souffert
non ce sont des variations annuelles donc
tant que vous avez des actions et de l'énergie
ressources pour avoir des stocks, c'est-à-dire des réfrigérateurs
choses etc ce n'est pas un gros problème dans le
moyen âge quand nous n'avions pas le
signifie avoir des stocks si nous avions une baisse de 40
en production au cours d'une année donnée personnes
sauriez-vous mourir de faim et révolutionner ainsi
ici pour le moment c'est abondant
une énergie qui nous permet de nous adapter à beaucoup
des choses qui se réfèrent à la seconde
bien sûr l'énergie abondante n'est pas éternelle
et l'essentiel ou la plupart des
les conséquences du réchauffement climatique
s'intensifient dans la seconde moitié du 21e
siècle à une époque où l'énergie abondante
en partie ne sera plus là
donc il va y avoir un effet de pince
c'est aussi pourquoi les conséquences sont
particulièrement difficile à prévoir dans
les gens en général qui s'intéressent à la
conséquences du réchauffement climatique, ils
raison comme beaucoup d'autres spécialistes tous
toutes choses étant égales par ailleurs pour eux
il n'y a pas l'ombre d'un doute qu'il y a
seront toujours des engrais efficaces
tracteurs produits phytosanitaires froid
chaînes etc sauf que ce n'est pas sûr
ou plus exactement il est certain qu'il
sera l'inverse après un
alors que ce n'est qu'une question de temps
donc dans les autres conséquences du climat
changer nous allons changer le microbien
biodiversité donc quelque chose de facile
comprendre, c'est que lorsque vous chauffez un
bouillon de culture tant qu'on ne le touche pas
trop mais juste le frapper un peu le
les petites créatures adorent ça et ainsi de suite dans un
monde qui se réchauffe à l'échelle mondiale, nous allons
ont tendance à favoriser l'augmentation des microbes
biodiversité qui a tendance comme vous
peut voir ici pour être plus haut dans le chaud
endroits donc là c'est être bouteille ça
c'est dire qu'à part te dire
que je ne peux pas t'en dire beaucoup plus
mais il est évident qu'il viendra un
moment où il y aura des nouveautés avec
en ce qui concerne les maladies et bien sûr cela
n'est pas le seul déclencheur de nouvelles maladies
loin de là donc je ne vais pas détailler ça
seulement que c'est parce que ce sou
ce n'est pas drôle du tout mais tu as
ici pour le Bangladesh
au sommet
la variation de euh
de cas de choléra
et en bas est la variation de
la température de surface du
eau du pacifique
donc ce que vous voyez c'est que lorsqu'il y a un
augmentation de la température de surface de
l'eau du pacifique donc dans ce cas le
Pacifique oriental, vous avez une augmentation de
le nombre de cas de choléra en
Bangladesh
savez-vous ce que la température augmente dans
le Pacifique oriental s'appelle
ça s'appelle el nino
quand vous êtes dans des conditions el nino
vous avez tendance à changer sous la pluie
régime
et donc
tu as euh
qu'est-ce que je disais euh tu as un
augmentation de l'eau saumâtre
au bangladesh c'est les eaux qui font
eau de mer et eau douce
qui favorise le développement de la
vibrio color ray pour avoir plus de monde
qui sont malades du coloriage alors voici
quelque chose que personne, je pense, n'aurait été
pouvoir en proposer un raisonnement
la nature à l'avance c'est-à-dire quand
il y a une augmentation de l'eau de surface
d'un paf pacifique tu vas avoir
plus de cas de calories
voilà donc c'est typiquement
le genre de conséquences que vous pouvez
comprendre après mais c'est très
difficile à prévoir avant
nous allons maintenant parler de la montée de la mer
niveau
alors voila tu as un schema
représentation très schématique même de
des terres émergées avec des montagnes sur lesquelles
il y a des glaciers sur certains
des océans et des calottes glaciaires que vous avez
ici donc tout cela participe à la
variation du niveau d'eau
la première chose qui arrivera est que
avec de l'eau est que comme je vous l'ai dit plus tôt
la quantité de chaleur emmagasinée par l'eau
augmente
l'eau chaude a tendance à prendre plus de volume
que l'eau froide puisque l'eau se dilate quand
ça chauffe et depuis le fond du
la baignoire ne varie toujours pas cela signifie que
le niveau de l'eau dans la baignoire
augmente lorsque vous chauffez l'eau et ainsi
le niveau de l'eau monte
la deuxième chose qui augmentera le
le niveau d'eau c'est quand tu fais fondre un glaçon
qui est posé sur terre
vous avez donc un premier glaçon ou une première série
de glaçons posés à terre qui sont
les glaciers des latitudes immédiates
généralement le mâle le verre pour ceux
de vous qui avez été au verre du milieu
et donc c'est à chamonix et tu as peut-être
vu avant de prendre les trains de monteverde
tu sais
retourner à la gare il y a
escaliers métalliques et le long de ces escaliers métalliques
escaliers, vous avez des panneaux qui vous indiquent comment
haut le simple verre était il y a 10 ans
il y a cinq ans il y a 20 ans etc et c'est
extrêmement spectaculaire il perd quelques
mètres tous les cinq ans je veux dire c'est
aller à une vitesse incroyable dans
épaisseur bien sûr et donc cette eau
puisqu'il n'est plus bien dans le verre
ça finit dans la mer
alors vous avez les bouchons qui auront
un impact sur le niveau d'eau donc les bouchons
peut avoir deux types ou trois types de
impacte plus précisément sur le niveau de l'eau
donc il y en a deux qui sont présentés ici
et le troisième j'en parlerai plus tard
le plafond passe de 5 000 mètres à
altitude au niveau de la mer à peu près depuis
où il vêle des icebergs où il finit
c'est au niveau de la mer et au sommet d'un
cap c'est une altitude de 3000 mètres donc
c'est comme prendre le lien avec le
verre melder c'est comme entre le
shawnee valley et le sommet du
le mont blanc c'est pas exactement pareil
Température
au bas de la casquette vous aurez
ont souvent des températures positives à
cette fois la glace fond et contribue
à la montée du niveau de la mer
mais au sommet d'une casquette tu as souvent
températures négatives ou même constamment
des températures négatives et donc là le
neiger
le toit qui tombe puise l'eau de la mer
l'eau était dans la mer elle s'évapore
ça tombe sur le bouchon et ça reste sur le
bouchon qui abaisse le niveau de la mer
donc en ce qui concerne les caps c'est
nécessaire de faire un bilan de masse qui
c'est ce qui y tombe moins ce qui s'en va
là et c'est la différence entre
les deux qui te disent si la glace
le plafond contribue au niveau de la mer
montée ou baisse du niveau de la mer
donc quand la calotte glaciaire se forme
la scandinavie évidemment ce qui s'y passe c'est
plus important ce qui s'y passe et le
le niveau de la mer baisse c'est ce que j'ai montré
vous plus tôt aujourd'hui c'est euh plutôt le
en face donc ce qui se passe là-bas est
supérieur à ce qui s'y passe et
donc le plafond contribue à la
montée du niveau de la mer
la fonte des glaces de mer puisque vous le savez tous
Archimède n'a pas d'impact sur l'eau
niveau
quand tu fais fondre de la glace qui flotte déjà dessus
la surface de l'eau monsieur archimède
vous dit qu'il ne bouge pas le
niveau d'eau
par contre mr notter communauté
c'est-à-dire que le physicien vous dit
qu'il a encore un impact parce que
vous remplacez un particulier
surface réfléchissante qui est bien la mer de glace
glace par le particulièrement absorbant
surface qui est de l'eau de mer qui
accélère le réchauffement de l'eau de mer
autour du bouchon et qui accélère la
la fonte ou la désintégration du bouchon
donc il n'y a pas d'effet direct mais il y a
un effet indirect
la glace de mer dans ce cas fond
c'est-à-dire et vous savez que c'est le
même dans votre vie tant qu'il y a
seront des journaux et des gens pour parler
bien régulièrement
peut-être pas tous les ans mais tu sais tous
quelques années on vous dira qu'on vient de casser
le record de l'étendue minimale de la glace de mer de
fin septembre donc voilà
parce que le processus a commencé et qu'il
se poursuivra parce que la montée de
la température est comme je l'ai dit plus tôt
prononcé dans l'Arctique que n'importe où
autre
il y a aussi une diminution du
épaisseur
de la banquise qui est
euh
qui est en cours
donc non seulement il diminue en étendue
mais il diminue en épaisseur donc on sait
l'épaisseur de la banquise depuis le
années 1970
est-ce que tu sais pourquoi
qui avait les moyens d'aller mesurer
épaisseur de la banquise depuis les années 1970
non pas l'huile
pire que le pétrole
des gens encore plus méchants que les anciens
entreprises
pas les chinois non non
les chinois n'ont qu'une seule compagnie pétrolière
oui militaire quel militaire
oui absolument les sous-mariniers
les gens qui ont opéré la balistique
lanceurs de sous-marins c'est le poétique
nom donné aux choses qui tirent nucléaire
missiles
eh bien ils ont mesuré l'épaisseur de la
glace de mer pour voir s'ils pourraient être capables de
surface à tout moment en errant
sous la banquise et ainsi ils mesurent
l'épaisseur d'une banquise et donc nous
avoir des records si longs séries sur plusieurs
des décennies sur l'épaisseur de la banquise
et c'est ainsi que nous savons qu'il
diminue
mais
la
le plus grand
mauvaise surprise potentielle pour le
siècles à venir
ce n'est pas de tout ça que ça viendra
ça vient des bouchons
la terre verte a commencé à fondre
nous savons que la terre verte a commencé à fondre
d'abord parce que les gens se promènent
dessus et surtout parce que nous sommes capables
faire radar arbre ultime c'est-à-dire
qu'il y a des satellites qui errent dans
la haute atmosphère bien quelques centaines
kilomètres de la terre et qui peuvent
mesurer avec des radars l'épaisseur
ils font des arbres ultimes donc ils mesurent
l'épaisseur du bouchon
si l'épaisseur d'un bouchon diminue c'est
que le bouchon a commencé à fondre une fois
le bouchon commence à fondre le processus lui-même
accélère
et s'accélère pendant plusieurs
raisons la première est que lorsque le plafond
fond son sommet perd en altitude et
quand certains il perd une altitude est
entouré d'air plus chaud et donc
il fond encore plus vite le deuxième processus
par lequel il se maintient est qu'à
le haut d'un bonnet tu as de la poussière qui est
emporté par le vent
ces poussières absorbent le rayonnement solaire
et la neige à la surface fond
mais pas la poussière
donc plus ça fond plus il y a de poussière
la concentration augmente puisqu'il ne
ont été apportés en permanence avec le
neige et vous vous retrouvez avec une densité de poussière
sur la surface qui augmente et
donc une surface qui absorbe davantage
rayonnement solaire, puis plus loin
amplifie le processus et ainsi
et puis vous avez un processus de fusion
glace de mer qui augmente également la
température dans une matière accélérée et
donc une fois qu'il démarre il ne s'arrête pas
la calotte glaciaire du groenland va fondre
partiellement ou complètement
dans les siècles à venir
en ce qui concerne l'antarctique vous
voir ici aussi le résultat d'un radar
arbre ultime et vous voyez que l'ouest
l'antarctique et en particulier cette partie
de l'ouest de l'Antarctique
a également commencé à perdre du volume
et donc là, le processus à l'œuvre est un
peu différent il s'avère que l'ouest
l'antarctique repose sur un socle rocheux
sous l'eau et qui draine c'est-à-dire
dire que plus on s'éloigne du
côte plus c'est profond
tant que vous avez les bits terminaux de
les glaciers qui commencent à se rétracter
donc parce que la température de la mer
monte et que le niveau de la mer monte un
peu
Eh bien, vous avez un processus de
déstabilisation de la glace qui se mange
loin d'en bas qui accélère
d'accord
et en plus cet ouest de l'antarctique est
placé sur une base qui a une pente et
c'est donc une sorte de système d'arc-boutant
chaque glacier consolide approximativement
glaciers voisins et lorsque vous avez
les glaciers terminaux qui sont
les voisins c qui commencent a destabiliser
vous avez le système d'arc-boutant
qui commence à se déstabiliser et donc là
est une possibilité que l'ouest de l'Antarctique
désagrégera complètement
dans quelques siècles si la température
augmente de plus de deux degrés
et donc puisque la température va monter
de plus de deux degrés euh eh bien je suis
sauter cette partie
eh bien, il est fort probable que nous soyons
va mettre en mouvement une partie ou
désintégration totale
ici aussi de l'ouest de l'antarctique sur le
l'échelle de quelques siècles donc ici vous
euh une simulation qui a été faite
récemment donc celui-ci est 2016. et quoi
tu vois c'est ça
avec ce scénario dans lequel nous ne sommes plus
émet demain matin tout va bien
mais avec le scénario 4.5 bien qu'il soit
pas un scénario très émissif bien nous
ont déjà une contribution possible
de l'antarctique de cinq mètres dans le
siècles à venir et avec le plus
scénario émissif auquel nous allons directement
12 mètres
donc nous avons
cinq à six mètres ici à plus de deux
degrés, nous sommes raisonnablement sûrs que
ils arriveront en même temps que nous
prendre trois à six mètres du groenland
et en même temps on prendra au moins
un mètre sur l'expansion de l'eau de mer
à cause de la température oui
donc ce ne sera pas forcément
homogène et j'y reviendrai
plus tard
donc pour vous donner une idée de ce que c'est
représente quelques mètres de plus dans
océan mondial, vous avez ici une carte dans laquelle
nous avons mis des endroits bleu foncé qui
va se noyer donc ici vous avez Bangkok pour
Exemple
qui va se noyer
avec une élévation de neuf mètres du niveau de la mer
et donc ici vous avez un shanghai attendez non
je ne me souviens pas que c'est l'europe du nord
donc voilà on parlait
sur la migration bien plus tôt
ben ben tu vois que les flamands sont
va envahir les ballons tu sais
ils ne s'entendent pas comme ça
ça ne va pas s'améliorer
donc jusqu'à
euh à propos de euh
il y a six mois
ce qui vient de la communauté scientifique
Était-ce un risque à l'horizon
de quelques siècles
depuis environ trois ou quatre mois
il y a des publications qui sont sorties
avec des gens disant que ça pourrait aller
plus vite qu'on ne l'imaginait donc plus vite que
nous imaginions pas la semaine prochaine mais peut-être
déjà dans un siècle très significatif
les choses vont arriver
donc ici aussi
nous sommes entrés dans un grand point d'interrogation
et le euh
[Musique]
comment dire ça
la grande particularité de cette question
la marque est que personne ne peut y répondre donc non
on peut vous donner une borne inférieure de la
troubles à venir
j'insiste dessus une grande incertitude je
insister est un gros risque
alors la question va-t-elle se manifester
réponds continuellement non
alors aujourd'hui vous avez une idée pour ceux de
vous qui avez déjà été en bretagne alors
excellente région d'ailleurs pour que vous puissiez
imaginez l'augmentation du niveau de l'eau
c'est comme la marée qui monte sur la plage
d'accord donc c'est très subtil très subtil et
en général tu es à la plage quand le
il fait beau pas quand il y a un niveau
10 tempête alors tu vois c'est bien ce n'est pas le cas
trop de vent etc et la chose monte
lentement mais bon si ça vous mouille les pieds
un peu tu retires juste la serviette
et c'est bon
donc on a tendance à oublier euh dans cette image
qu'après que l'eau monte, elle remonte
vers le bas qu'il ne s'élève pas au-dessus d'un
certain niveau et qu'il
arrive quand il fait beau et
doux etc et qu'il ne concerne que
sable parce que vous avez la haute mer
laisse qui est encore du sable et donc le
tout l'estran est recouvert de sable et
son épée est une zone prévue pour
vétérinaires
concernant verizon dans les choses au niveau de la mer
vont se présenter un peu
différemment parce que vous avez un milliard
les choses humaines qui intéressent les hommes
qui sont construits au bord de la mer, vous avez donc
les ports en général les ports ne sont pas
placé dans des terres, il est plus pratique de
les avoir au bord de la mer sauf que les ports
ne peut supporter une hausse indéfinie de
l'eau de mer parce que si vous avez
une élévation trop élevée du niveau de la mer, vous
noyer toutes les infrastructures qui sont
dans le port donc vous avez beaucoup de
entrepôts stocks de toutes sortes chemin de fer
terminaux et cetera toutes les choses qui
n'aime pas être noyé dans l'eau de mer
donc vous avez des raffineries parce qu'un grand
une partie du raffinage concerne l'essence
qui est amené par des pétroliers
et il est plus pratique d'avoir un
pétrolier sur l'eau plutôt que dans le
milieu de la région de bose donc raffineries
êtes au bord de la mer vous avez beaucoup de
centrales électriques qui sont par le
mer pour refroidir par exemple tous les
centrales électriques au japon non seulement
orbite nucléaire c et première approximation
vous avez des silos agricoles parce qu'un
bonne partie d'un commerce de grain est fait par
vraquier
donc les silos agricoles vous avez un bon
partie qui sont au bord de la mer et cetera et
donc vous avez beaucoup de choses importantes
qui sont au bord de la mer et donc vous avez aussi
quelques villes donc vous avez beaucoup de choses
qui sont au bord de la mer et ces choses sont
protégé contre les agressions des
mer parce que de temps en temps la mer est
un peu méchant donc tu as une tempête avec
une grosse dépression et donc le niveau de l'eau
se lève et pour ceux d'entre vous qui regardent le
après les tempêtes ont généralement de l'eau
appelées surtensions lors d'orages, c'est-à-dire
Dire que le niveau de l'eau monte
de façon spectaculaire et cette montée du niveau de l'eau
peut noyer tout un tas de choses derrière
alors quelle sera la montée du niveau de l'eau
le fera rapprochera-t-il du bord de mer
toutes les infrastructures que je viens de mentionner
et c'est à l'occasion d'extrême
phénomènes comme il y en a toujours eu et
sera toujours
en ce moment la mer passe sur
défenses et fait d'énormes dégâts derrière
de sorte que la montée du niveau de l'eau ne sera pas
produisent des conséquences douces et
continu
d'accord ce n'est pas comme ça que ça va
ça va arriver sur le
occasion de violence discontinue
phénomènes c'est ainsi que les phénomènes
se produire vous avez aussi dans les avions bas
parfois la conjonction d'un orage
parce que cela arrive souvent en hiver et
inondations terrestres parce qu'il pleut
beaucoup et en ce moment c'est le
conjonction d'un deux qui apporte de l'eau
d'un côté à l'autre et bam toi
ont un processus qui est particulièrement
destructeur
donc je vais sauter ça parce que je
n'ai pas le temps
vous avez aussi dans les conséquences que
sont possibles donc je viendrai au Groenland
en une seconde une modification à grande échelle
des circulations que vous avez dans le
océan
à cause des alizés
qui poussent constamment l'eau dans le
Même direction
à l'équateur et à partir du coriolis
force tu as un grand mouvement de
circulation dans les océans du monde
qui s'organise à peu près comme suit
est un grand mouvement est-ouest sur la
surface faisant le tour de l'afrique par le sud
et un grand mouvement inverse dans le
profondeurs avec ici l'eau
tu connais la plongée
alors pourquoi l'eau plonge-t-elle au sud de
Groenland
parce qu'il s'avère que l'eau
est particulièrement dense lorsqu'il est
particulièrement froid et particulièrement salé
donc dans le sud du groenland vous
ont
l'eau qui est
enrichi à séoul ​​parce que quand il est allé
vers le nord à travers l'atlantique
l'évaporation conduit en partie à
les précipitations qui se sont terminées en europe
et qui n'a pas
s'écoulent vers la même partie de l'atlantique
les rivières apportent de l'eau douce pas dans le
même endroit d'où vient l'eau
où il a perdu de l'eau douce et est devenu
plus salé et donc quand vous arrivez au sud
Groenland donc vous êtes dans une formation de glace
région où la banquise se forme donc la banquise
c'est de l'eau salée gelée mais c'est moins
salée que l'eau de mer dont elle
est né et donc il expulse de la saumure
se forme donc l'eau de mer se forme et elle expulse
saumure qui signifie que l'eau qui
ne gèle pas devient soudainement plus salé
et à ce moment il devient particulièrement
froid c'est l'hiver et particulièrement salé
et il plonge il devient plus dense que le
l'eau qui était en dessous et il plonge
cette plongée en eau profonde est comme un siphon
d'accord c'est un mouvement vers le bas
qui est comme un siphon et c'est parce que
de ce mouvement de siphon que vous avez
la dérive nord-atlantique qui remonte
au sud du groenland d'ailleurs depuis
ce mouvement enterre la chaleur de surface c'est
à cause de ça
que le réchauffement est moins prononcé
au sud du Groenland parce que vous avez un
pompe à chaleur qui récupère la chaleur
surface et l'enterre alors que cette chaleur
la pompe n'existe pas dans le reste du
l'océan d'accord et c'est l'existence
de cette pompe à chaleur dans le vrai sens de
un mot je veux dire ça pompe la chaleur que tu
avoir un réchauffement qui est moins prononcé que
tant que cette plongée en eau profonde a lieu
comme
bien sûr si cette plongée en eau profonde s'arrête
c'est une question que ça pourrait arriver à ça
temps la perte de chaleur de la surface par
l'enterrement s'arrête aussi et puis tu non
ont plus la singularité au sud
Groenland
tu sais ça te dit la même chose
en coupe transversale, alors la question pourrait-elle
la circulation affaiblit les réponses oui
parce que dans un monde soumis à la mondialisation
échauffement
eh bien le réchauffement des tropiques est moindre
important que le réchauffement de l'Arctique
et donc la différence de chaleur entre
l'arctique et les tropiques s'affaiblit
et donc le fait qu'il fragilise
diminue un peu la différence de potentiel
entre les deux et donc ça va
affaiblir la circulation
et donc ce que les simulations vous montrent est
que um presque tous s'attendent à ce que
est une diminution de la circulation du
la dérive de l'atlantique nord donc le nord
dérive atlantique exprimée en statisme de sphère
ce sont des millions de mètres cubes par
seconde comme notre manga l'écoulement du sable
rivière est de 400 mètres cubes par seconde donc
on ne parle pas des mêmes commandes
de magnitude bien il y en a beaucoup qui
pense que ça va diminuer mais il y a
personne qui pense que ça s'arrêtera brusquement
cependant il y a eu des épisodes dans le
passé où cette circulation s'est arrêtée
brusquement pendant les périodes glaciaires
à des moments où il y a eu d'énormes
les éruptions d'icebergs qui ont eu lieu dans le
l'atlantique nord et qui a tant apporté
eau douce que l'eau n'était plus
assez dense parce qu'il n'était plus
assez salé pour pouvoir plonger et à
cette fois la circulation s'arrête et nous
peut le voir avec des modifications très rapides
sur des échelles de temps très courtes de la végétation
en trouvant des pollens dans la carotteuse
échantillons de sédiments près de la côte
on s'est rendu compte que la végétation a
complètement changé en quelques décennies
et cela est attribuable à une
modification de ce thermoalign
circulation
autre conséquence euh phénomènes extrêmes
devraient s'intensifier et c'est un
processus qui est déjà à l'œuvre comme je
dit plus tôt je veux dire dans le précédent
les phénomènes extrêmes sont liés à une
convection entre
une surface chaude et une stratosphère froide
et avec une stratosphère qui se refroidit
sur cette surface qui chauffe et un
évaporation qui augmente globalement vous
avoir une pompe convective d'intensification tous
raison et donc logiquement nous nous attendons à ce que
tout comme les tornades les ouragans
etc et les cyclones augmentent
donc ce que nous observons est que le nombre de
cyclones dans l'atlantique nord a une
tendance à augmenter légèrement mais au-dessus
toute leur intensité tend fortement
augmenter ici vous avez une évolution de
l'intensité des phénomènes cycloniques dans
l'atlantique et vous voyez que le
phénomènes de catégories quatre et cinq
ont considérablement augmenté au fil des
dernières décennies
donc en d'autres termes pour le moment là
y a peut-être quelques cyclones de plus que
avant c'est pas très clair de l'autre
part ce qui est très clair c'est que tu as
cyclones plus intenses qui apparaissent
et en fait c'est exactement ce que nous sommes
s'attendre au réchauffement futur
tu as ici une carte ben c'est par bassin
et puis pour le plan dans son ensemble mais bon
je vais juste vous donner ça directement
le point important est que vous voyez le
euh
les précipitations et le vent
ont tendance à augmenter en intensité
en d'autres termes, il n'y aura pas
forcément des phénomènes plus cycloniques
par contre en moyenne quand ils
se formeront, ils auront tendance à être plus
destructeur
autre question qui est posée sommes-nous
va modifier le el nino la nina
oscillation au moment où la réponse est
pas clair il y a un peu de début de
une tendance mais tu sais là
et c'est aussi une question parce que
va amplifier le disons 10 ans
extrêmes parce que le plus intense el
nino et la nina sont plus vous avez
extrêmes importants par rapport à
la tendance
autre conséquence de ce qui se passe
l'océan deviendra acide
donc le fait que l'océan s'acidifie
est quelque chose de physique
une partie d'un co2 va dans l'eau
il s'agit d'un équilibrage de pression partiel
une fois que le co2 est allé dans l'eau, il
fait une réaction où cela conduira à
la formation de euh
les hydrogénocarbonates je pense que c'est comme ça
nous disons de nos jours et h plus ions donc il
va acidifier l'eau donc vous savez que
le co2 dans l'antiquité était appelé carbonique
acide si vous lisez des romans de vern bijou
c'est comme ça que ça s'appelle donc j'en ai mis plus
co2 dans l'eau j'ai acidifié l'eau
s'avère que
de quelle acidification il s'agit
faire est quelque chose qui est à nouveau
extrêmement perturbant par rapport à ce
le ph de l'océan était au moins supérieur
les 25 derniers millions d'années qui a été
remarquablement stable et vous voyez ici comment
le ph peut évoluer
des horizons temporels très très courts par rapport
aux échelles géologiques
donc évidemment il y a plusieurs
animaux dans l'océan qui sont
habitués à ce ph très stable
en commençant par les coraux mais aussi en commençant
avec plusieurs espèces qui
besoin de synthétiser le calcaire et dans
aragonite particulière donc l'aragonite est un
forme de calcaire donc vous avez deux formes
calcite et aragonite qui sont
synthétisé par un certain nombre d'organismes planctoniques
espèces pour faire de petites coquilles
bien s'ils ne peuvent pas faire ces petits
coquilles plus ces espèces disparaissent
ils meurent donc une partie d'un plancton est à
risque dans cette histoire
donc je vais sauter ça parce que je n'ai pas
temps
et je vais sauter ça aussi parce que je ne le fais pas
avoir le temps
donc au bout d'une chaine il y a nous
ce graphique est là pour vous rappeler que
les risques pour la santé qui est de sauver le
risques pour l'espèce humaine qu'ils viennent
à la fois des choses que nous avons vu si
loin
encore une fois si nous ne mangeons pas nous n'allons pas bien
et puis ils peuvent provenir d'indirects
risques c'est-à-dire si c'est le
voisin qui ne peut pas manger le quartier
commence à entrer en état de guerre et le
voisin arrive chez nous pour que nous puissions
avons assez à manger, nous serons encore à
risque à cause du changement climatique parce que
nous allons avoir une conséquence qui
n'est pas une conséquence physique directe mais
une conséquence géopolitique
je ne crois pas qu'il y ait un
logiciel fiable pour la prévision de guerre
bien en tout cas à moyen et long terme
je ne pense pas que ce sera très simple
d'autre part quelque chose qui est
raisonnablement robuste comme une conclusion est
qu'à partir du moment où tu as un euh
comment dire tu as une pression globale
constitution du système
c'est que vous avez du lichen avec plaque
tectonique
les personnes qui sont globalement sous augmentation
stress à la surface d'une planète, c'est
pas très difficile à comprendre ça
fondamentalement, les conflits vont augmenter
ce sera globalement le cas
dernier point je vais maintenant vous montrer
les effets de causalité
autour du cycle du carbone dans le climat
qui euh qui est
une chose importante dans ce qui nous concerne
donc ici vous avez un diagramme qui
représente les flux et les stocks de
carbone sur terre
avec en noir la situation telle qu'elle était
avant que l'humanité ne fasse quelque chose au
climat
et en rouge les modifications qui
intervenu au milieu des années 1990 en relation
à la situation préindustrielle
donc ce que ce graphique vous dit, c'est que pour
exemple dans la situation préindustrielle
l'océan échange du carbone avec
atmosphère pourquoi
car il s'avère que l'eau de mer
la capacité à dissoudre le co2 est plus élevée lorsque
l'eau est froide
donc n'importe où sur la surface de la terre
où tu as des courants
qui refroidissent l'eau que vous avez vers le bas
flux de co2 donc par exemple le golfe
stream est ou plutôt l'atlantique nord
la dérive plus précisément est une pompe à co2 donc
l'eau se refroidit en allant vers
terre verte et donc elle pompe du co2 conserver
sortant du courant du labrador qui est un
courant qui vient du nord froid
et dont l'eau chauffe en allant
sud
c'est un émetteur de co2
évidemment le co2 qui a été
absorbé à un endroit est de la place à un autre
et les soldes du système vous avez un
deuxième flux naturel de co2 entre le
atmosphère et terre émergée
qui est le cycle de la végétation
donc grandir
les plantes prélèvent du carbone dans l'atmosphère
co2
mais après les plantes sont mangées
soit par des animaux macroscopiques vous pour
exemple ou par des animaux microscopiques, il est
la décomposition des plantes mortes et à
ce moment la respiration libère ce
co2 à l'atmosphère et à la respiration
vous avez évidemment un micro-organisme
respiration
ce que vous remarquez, c'est qu'avant de jouer du violon
avec le système les flux sont globalement
équilibré donc tu fais ça et ça et
ça et ça et le ruissellement ici et
bam c'est équilibré donc le ruissellement passe par
sangsue par l'eau de pluie
puis viennent les hommes
et les femmes
alors que faisons-nous
nous allons faire deux choses
allons déboiser et nous allons
détruire les combustibles fossiles donc dans les deux cas
nous prendrons le carbone qui était en stock
la végétation ou les combustibles fossiles et collez-le
dans l'atmosphère
ce faisant, nous augmentons les quantités de
co2 dans l'atmosphère
ce faisant, nous augmentons la température
de l'atmosphère à cette époque depuis le
la température monte
l'eau de surface se réchauffe
et qu'oliver, toutes choses étant égales par ailleurs, envoie
plus de co2 dans l'air
c'est le processus dont je vous ai parlé à
le temps des variations naturelles de
climat quand j'ai dit quand astronomique
les paramètres réchauffent le climat il envoie du co2
dans l'air et il amplifie le
traiter
mais en même temps puisque tu as plus
co2 dans l'atmosphère que dans l'océan
en pression partielle vous créerez un
flux descendant de co2 de l'atmosphère
à l'océan
donc il s'avère que par chance pour ainsi dire
actuellement les deux sont à peu près équilibrés
mais c'est de la chance car on vient d'un
différence de pression partielle et la
l'autre provient d'une variation de température
Donc voilà
concernant les terres émergées
initialement plus de co2 dans l'air c'est plus
nourriture pour les plantes afin que les plantes aient un
tendance à augmenter la photosynthèse
c'est ainsi que nous accélérons le métabolisme de
plants de tomates dans les serres de
Nantes c'est en enrichissant leur
ambiance en co2 grace a quoi un kilo
de nœuds de tomates vertes vaut presque un kilo
de gaz
mais en même temps vous avez un
augmentation de la température qui
favorise
métabolisme microbien
et donc la respiration de
microbes donc l'émission de co2 par
terres émergées
mais avec le temps
il s'avère que l'augmentation de
Température
sera
intensifier
après que le co2 cesse d'augmenter
et à ce moment-là vous allez avoir
une intensification du carbone
les émissions par les sols que vous allez avoir
un affaiblissement de la photosynthèse car
les écosystèmes auront de plus en plus
difficulté à supporter la hausse
la température et le stress hydrique et avec
en ce qui concerne l'océan où vous allez
avoir une intensification du co2 libéré
par l'eau en même temps que le
les pressions partielles finiront par rebondir
et donc que le flux descendant
va descendre donc ce que je te montre
est que vous avez ici un ensemble de positif
boucles de rétroaction que vous voyez
ce qui donne malheureusement au système
capacité à se laisser emporter à cause de
la rétroaction du climat sur le cycle du carbone
donc ça finira toujours par l'amortir
finira toujours par trouver un
point d'équilibre mais malheureusement ce
le point d'équilibre est susceptible d'être trouvé
beaucoup trop haut
et je finirai avec le temps caractéristique
compétences en la matière
ici vous avez une perspective sur la façon dont le
divers processus dont je vous ai parlé
vont être décalés dans le temps
à ce sujet donc ici vous avez
comment les émissions de co2 vont-elles
évoluer
vous voyez qu'ils augmentent et au
au plus tard en raison de la géologie
limitation des stocks d'énergies fossiles il
va pour un maximum puis il diminue
et je dis au plus tard à cause de
qu'il peut diminuer plus tôt et nous devons
j'espère que si toutes les conséquences je viens
mentionnés ne semblent pas assez attrayants
pour que nous décidions que ça vaut le coup
problèmes
à cause de l'inertie chimique donc co2
est un oxyde donc chimiquement stable
à cause de l'inertie chimique du co2
dans l'atmosphère, vous pouvez voir qu'il est
pas quand on passe le maximum de
émissions que nous dépassons le maximum dans
concentration donc lorsque les émissions
commencer à diminuer c'est-à-dire quand
vous êtes soit en stress énergétique soit
soit on commence à faire des efforts
d'un côté ou de l'autre dans tous les cas
la première chose que les gens verront, c'est que
la concentration continuera à
augmenter
donc c'est une situation compliquée mais si
tu dis merde soit on est en plus et
plus de problèmes et nous voyons que le
la concentration augmente de toute façon tu sais
parce que nous n'avons pas assez d'énergie
plus ou nous aurons commencé à faire
efforts et nous constatons que
la concentration augmente quand même
de toute façon ça va être un
situation compliquée à expliquer
la température va continuer à dériver
longtemps après que nous ayons dépassé le maximum de
émissions
très longtemps après avoir dépassé un maximum
des émissions
et enfin en ce qui concerne la réponse
des océans dans la cryosphère
les conséquences vont s'alourdir
pendant des milliers d'années après que nous ayons
passé le maximum d'émissions donc je
répéter ce que j'ai dit quand j'ai parlé de
inertie chimique du co2 dans l'air
fait, le changement climatique est un système dans lequel
il n'y a aucun moyen de guérir
donc on peut prévenir on peut s'adapter mais on
ne pouvons pas guérir dans le sens où nous ne pouvons pas
éliminer la cause d'une maladie
c'est ce qu'il faut retenir
alors ce que je dis encore même si ce n'est pas le cas
trop sympathique à la
euh
à la génération que vous avez éventuellement
représenter
est-ce
c'est un processus qui malheureusement
seulement grandir et embellir jusqu'à ce que je meure et
jusqu'à ce que tu meurs quoi qu'on fasse en tout cas
avec lesquels nous travaillons pour nos enfants
en ce qui concerne l'amortissement du
conséquences mais c'est à cette échelle
que ça arrive
qu'il faut se garder de penser
que ce que nous ne savons pas est une absence
de risque parce qu'en général c'est comme ça qu'on
raison malheureusement ce n'est pas le chemin
raisonner en l'espèce et
enfin la dernière phrase revient à
la première leçon et c'est absolument
essentiel
une partie importante de votre vie sera
passé dans un monde où l'accès à
l'énergie deviendra un problème croissant pour
un nombre croissant de zones autour du
monde, ce qui signifie que la capacité de
répondre à un problème aura tendance à s'affaiblir
avec le temps
c'est une autre façon de dire que nous
devrions allouer nos ressources à la prise
s'occuper d'un problème pendant que nous avons encore
certains au lieu de penser que le temps joue
en notre faveur et que demain nous ferons
avoir des robots drones et dieu sait quoi
chose artificielle qui le fera
possible de traiter un problème plus
facilement même aujourd'hui d'accord en fait
puisque c'est l'énergie qui est en premier
ordre d'une procuration de notre capacité à
gérer quoi que ce soit si nous avons moins c'est
pas malheureusement essentiellement un
des découvertes techniques qui compenseront
pour cela à la première commande
ça ne marchera pas bien
là donc
à la prochaine